it up light it up and paul you better
have some opinions paul this is like a
tryout
i'm ready you got the ucla uh because
he's got a mic try outs buddy
mario you got a mic as well mario's got
a mic we gotta we gotta talk to mario
and say
mario tell me who wins the super bowl
and why yes
wow by the way isn't the super bowl this
weekend yeah this weekend
today's thursday yeah is that not on the
super bowls
we've already started we're already live
at them
we are officially live everybody
you know how long it's been how long has
it been since the last part it feels
like years but how long has it been
officially tell us i want you to tell us
how long has it been
i think it's been since early january
before all the drama
i want to say here we got in the notes
last time
according to our buddy kai last time we
were together on a podcast was
january 7th which is what exactly how
long it's been
four weeks give or take since we did the
last podcast so
i i i think we got a lot to share a lot
of you guys have been sending messages i
know you've got a bunch of soy boy mafia
type of messages that's been sent your
way where the hell are you guys where
are you what was the one that
was sent to you yesterday give us this
guy this guy was like all right enough's
enough the jig is up like we need an
explanation we demand
an explanation where the hell have you
been where have you been so pat
let me tee this up for you where the
hell have we been yeah
so so uh first of all listen man you
know i gotta tell you
if there's one thing i've missed is the
podcast because there this is a
uh a way of us talking you know issues
different thing that's going on have fun
it's entertaining it's community people
are involved
um the last four weeks a ton has
happened january 7th was what what
day was january 7th what day was january
7th paul
was the day after the insurrection i
believe so if we look at january 7th
it's a thursday thursday okay so january
7th
prior to that i had an event january
uh second third and fourth i had an
event with around 4 500 people
that came to uh to dallas right we had a
great event it was phenomenal it was
fantastic
came out you know better than we
expected just a great turnout on him we
came out the gates we had a great
january
uh up nearly 80 percent january over
january over last year
it's been a good year it's been a good
year 2021's been a great start
but despite all the challenges here's
what happened january 8th
i'm going to dinner yep with mural and
tikran
because they treated us to this place
called uh
knife is there a place called knife in
dallas is there a place called knife in
dallas
i think it's knife in dallas let me tell
you knife if you're listening
food was absolutely delicious and guess
who got the bill
morale and t can got the bills i got to
give a shout out to more all in tikrit
and this was a nice kind of a restaurant
who's like my favorite couple yeah yeah
i mean listen i think it's everyone's
favorite couple you get to know those
guys i'm the godfather of their son
that's right that's right that's right
so and uh and i'm team dante because
dante and i have a connection together
yeah yeah so
sam my friends so so anyways we go to
dinner i come back i get in the car that
night in dallas i felt like it was five
degrees and it was pretty cold and windy
come home i'm shaking i said i don't
know what's going on my body the next
day i go get tested
and i test positive okay boom so here we
go so
covet so i have to quarantine the entire
time i'm quarantining i got a wife who's
four months pregnant carrying we have to
move we have the movers coming in we
have
you know the estate sale we have the
18-wheeler coming and grabbing the stuff
that we're moving we have to go to the
office we have to go drag this stuff out
of the office
put it in the truck jen is getting the
play scored away
that we're moving out here everything is
going on perfect timing
perfect timing is what it is to kick off
the year
and uh and at the same time we are
officially in florida we've been
planning this move to florida for quite
some time just so we just made the
announcement
official if you're asking we are
officially back
uh uh we are officially in florida we
want to tell them what city we're in or
we can't tell them what city we're we
are in boca raton
that's where we are we are in boca for
now we're in boca that's where we are we
are involved 45 minutes uh
north of miami we're about a half hour
south of palm beach yep
yeah i know you visited at mar-a-lago
recently yeah you know a potential uh
2024 candidate you're not going to
happen here i'm uh
we're trying to talk about the rules
we'll see we will we will talk a lot
today we got a lot to talk about today
so the covet thing happened and uh i
think something happened to you as what
with the covet situation yeah i mean
i didn't get it at the knife with the
morale and tigran yeah
i i you got it with the with the going
to
uh that was with the the nurse uh he
went to the er with the nurse
was there a nurse involved with so go
tell us obviously a nurse involved yeah
for sure that's my that's my niche these
days
i got it uh probably parting in south
beach over new year's i thought
literally yeah probably i don't know or
i might have got it
with dallas uh with the rest of the crew
because there's like
four or five hundred other people we
know in dallas who got covered
but i think the moral of the story is
this we've been talking about
kovid yeah and this pandemic how was it
you know for for months and months and
months but how was it like you've read
all these things yeah you don't know
what people tell you how it was for the
house
we've had conversations you know it's
kind of you kind of need to like go
through something before you can kind of
give your opinion yeah
so we've been talking about covet and
businesses that are shutting down should
remain open should they not stimulus
checks this and that
and i think we can agree covet's not fun
right like you lost 10 pounds
i had i went from 246 to 226
246 20 pounds 246 to 226 one week
you lost 20 pounds in one in a week let
me tell you when i saw
my dude my abs i look like a calvin
klein model oh damn six four and a half
running middle eastern calvin klein my
absolutely out i'm like this
you know calvin klein likes the
extremely skinny guy yeah coca-cola laws
i
get like so minus that no so yeah i mean
i for me i just couldn't eat
i simply couldn't eat so i couldn't keep
anything down
so i could barely eat anything the only
thing i could eat was chicken noodle
soup
but i did every single one of my
conference calls every single one of my
zooms every single one of
anything and everything i had to do
everything was done and no one knew
about it
right the only people that knew about
the fact that i had coveted were
people that work on a daily basis my
board and that was it not even the
people you didn't even know
no not if you were living in the other
room in the house i was living in four
seasons
and i was quarantined at a room all the
way on the other side
no nothing yeah zilch zero i couldn't
have contact with those guys
and we did it the right way you know i
live with uh our nanny who's
in her 60s i didn't want to have her
anything nothing happened to her nothing
happened to jen nothing happened to the
kids it's always properly done
and uh now it's been a while so
everybody scored away and it's good to
go but
again going back to it yeah the most
annoying thing about
covet is it's going to take time away
from you that's it
for me i mean for from my experience
when i'm noticing from everybody it's
just it's gonna take
a week or two away from you and it's
frustrating
what was the worst symptom you had yeah
so basically uh
uh i got back to i was in miami i got
back to dallas a couple days later i
started feeling weird uh
for those of you that have not had
coveted here's my story i had three days
that i i was at a friday after work
obviously paul our friend over there
who's behind the scenes he's like
gekko you ready for the gecko that's our
friday night spot in dallas shout out to
the greatest
bar in the history of bars the gecko in
uh they don't need an advertising budget
just listen to the podcast you know
we're sending people together
we're killing it and i said i think i'm
gonna sit this one out guys i don't
think
it's time for the gecko and that's when
paul knew something was up if we're not
hitting the gecko on a friday night
so that what was that that's a big deal
it's a big deal
by the way did paul ever end up going on
a date with the girl from gekko or
no but he did buy his uh her boyfriend
dinner out of respect
yeah so respect much respect i bought it
i respect
your girlfriend oh never caught her back
he also showed her his ron burgundy
outfit on halloween
hold on are you really though we're
gonna have to we got mario here that's
mario's voice mario asked the elephant
in the room
oh my goodness mario by the way mario is
going to give us an analysis i was going
to win the super bowl this weekend
well i can't wait to go just deep on
super bowl i'm really i'm sure you can
i aged and got a great tan and looks a
little easier he gave me a promotion
i said i had permission
here's what most people don't know
here's what most people don't know mario
was a spelling bee uh a champion or
expert or so he wants something in
spelling bee
anytime i want to spell anything i go to
mario he's the guy
i'm telling you mario is a ridiculous
speller i don't know where that gift
came
from yeah no no but we're going to do it
today because today he's going to do the
search in english not in
you know kaiser norway adding the
additional 16 whatever else is the
viking keyboard you're not going to
prank us so
so tell us what's the worst so basically
what's the worst something three days
that i felt like i just got the [ __ ]
kicked out of me by like
jumped in in high school three days
sitting in bed doing nothing
no cough no cold no symptoms no fever no
nothing no
and then um good to go then i was good
to go so basically i had to shoot like
you said the show goes on
yeah i had to shoot my my money episodes
yeah sales talks money in my apartment i
had to do the business in the apartment
i had to do zoom calls thank god for
zoom
thank god for facetime thank god for
technology and
you know a week later or ten days later
i tested negative two times and now
uh i'm back in florida and we're we're
having a good go buddy there you go
yeah but i think the bigger story here
is maybe the lessons that we can take
from all this
something like this uh let's give both
sides of the coin
it should not shut down the entire
freaking us economy
or the world yeah that's one side of the
equation like let's not
shut things down gyms bars restaurants
like we get it but at the same time
we're young we're in our early 40s you
know maybe in our 30s
20s what have you um but we do need to
protect older people
like you pointed out mario at 20.
mario's not in it's not okay
i didn't say anything there's only one
person here in his 20s and it's not
mario but go ahead
and and the person back there that
remains to be named because he might not
be here
but older people i can see why they're
like holy [ __ ] they're not they're going
to make it so
it is real yeah the people whose are
like it's a scam damage and ain't real i
ain't wearing a mask it's like grow up
guys like there's people in the society
that um depend on us taking this
seriously but for the most part 99 of us
we're gonna have a shitty week or two
and move on with our lives but the
biggest question is i think these days
is
can you get it again i don't know i
don't know what have you found i mean
we're going to we're going to find out
if you can or cannot i mean can you get
flu again can you can you get bronchitis
again i hope not
can you get you know i mean of course
you can get it again so
uh uh you know the the idea of that you
can't get it again it's a it's a bit of
a myth i think you can't get it again
but it is what
by the way if you've had it yourself as
well and you're watching this why don't
you comment below and tell us what was
the worst symptom that you had
uh that was mine that was his and by the
way we were almost not gonna do today's
podcast because
we are barely getting the office settled
and as you can tell the wall is still
green on this side that wall is not
gonna stay green
though the walls painted black here we
got our buddy joker and uh
batman here hawk won't fit in this
because the it's just he's he's 9-3 and
this alone is yeah eight uh we got a lot
of different things that we had
we should address that this is a
temporary office yeah right we just
moved to florida we've been unpacking
we've been moving we've been hustling
yeah
we kind of targeted this day shout out
to you eric mickey
mario working day and night getting this
whole place set up i mean seriously the
team
worked their tails off making sure this
thing came together and everybody else
that was on the outside working doing
their part obviously this was a very
shout out to this guy right here i mean
first and foremost this guy locked in
no question about it he's meeting with
he has to go meet with these beautiful
realtors that he's falling in love it's
tough it's tough
out there to be to be mario but
the the team's here in south florida
we're here now so it's good
watches mr zex i lost 35 pounds when i
had kovit okay
uh uh what else we got okay good morning
enough oh
it's like your head situation like for
me my head
was the worst thing and i was bedridden
literally for
eight days and that work yeah that was
like i couldn't
i couldn't even that's our friend paul
by the way paul
aka the gecko um that's mine you must
have had it worse than anybody
from out of all of us you had the worst
yeah i had it pretty much were you the
first one like eight months ago so i
started this uh
movie you kicked this thing off i
started the soyboy mafia movement yeah
you started the dallas cove
i started congratulations yeah nice
shout out to eric galera he's here he's
a former marine
he's a stud he's been uh you know making
things happen over here he's massed up
he's muffled up but
shout out and there's some shady guy
behind you i don't know who that guy is
but pat let's get back to you you've
been planning you know you wrote this
uh wall street journal best-selling book
your next five moves
so you're the guy who knows about making
moves you started off in
california you were there for 20-plus
years you moved to texas to
really grow your five years yeah for
five years you've been planning this
move to florida for
i assume at least a year or so now no
i'm gonna have to say
yeah march of last year it started
because
the moment the pandemic started i
watched how calif because we were
supposed to go to greenwich and go to
new york that's what the plan was so we
we looked at a lot of stuff in greenwich
we looked at a lot of stuff in new york
i love that area i love the
you know the dog fight the competition
the energy of new yorkers it's a
beautiful place to be
or we were going to go back to
california because california is all my
contacts and
my friends my you know family
relationships
and then it was dallas and then last
minute because we love going to the
breakers
regularly we love the breakers and i
said how about florida
yeah so then jen said why don't we go
take a look at florida a little bit more
we did and then we started looking at
homes we said let's look at schools we
looked at five six seven schools
we fell in love with the swan school and
then finally we said you know let's
let's make the move because
i've said this before and i'll keep
saying this if california and texas had
a baby
it's florida simple as that california
weather you got florida weather here
california's got earthquakes you got
hurricanes over here
texas has got no taxes you ain't paying
taxes here
florida's a little bit purple which
means you got left you got middle you
got right which is great we're
reasonable here
exactly what i'm trying to tell you is a
little bit of everything and if you like
new york you'll like here because most
people from new york
are leaving to come here so uh all of
that combined together led to what it is
today we're leaving the headquarters
obviously in dallas we're not moving the
headquarters of uh
uh php that stays put in dallas and uh
here this is purely a valentine
headquarters that we have this is not a
php
you've been you've been you've been
operating php you're in your financial
services company and valuetainment out
of the same office
same headquarters for a long time for
five plus years now so now they are
officially
they need room to have more employees
exactly and we were kind of like timing
was getting in the way and php so those
two
we were the loud crazy roommates they're
trying to let me tell you i went there
this week i was there this monday right
i went to
texas this monday all day all morning i
was with him we had our awards ceremony
got to give a shout out to mvps okafor
schwazo ricky and erica let me see if i
can remember everybody i'm going to miss
one paula probably
apollo was mvp but i'm missing one oh
phelp what's
mvp forget about michael you give these
guys statues
16. i saw these statues bust it was just
ridiculous what we did but uh when i
walked in
it was very quiet like you couldn't hear
whispers
you know how people go typing like you
could hear all this stuff right when i
walked in
and then i realized the reason why it's
so quiet because all the loudness
of valuetainment were all gone you
weren't there you alone count for 19
people if you're really thinking
the amount of noise yes adam makes
should equate to 19 average human being
would you agree with that it's 18 to 19.
i can't tell you how many times people
get sh
i'm constantly being told to be quiet
i've never been told speak up buddy i've
never heard that
especially the ping-pong games uh during
working hours those were always
did you end up being ranked first place
before you left this is number one thing
on my resume right now who's beat you
the most though
out of anyone so number one i was the
number one ping-pong player in all of
these
but who's beating me the most yeah was
you well really you yes so who's who
who what so i love you the most you also
would not stop playing unless you beat
me like one time
i remember one two three games in a row
let me tell you one time i'm trying to
go home to make you to dinner right
and we go one game okay no one more time
okay we go second game one more time
you remember how many times you beat me
in a row it was like 15 or so you beat
me 13 games in a row okay
and by the way at this point i had no
clue can swipe playing ping pong by the
way we're sweating you know
it's pat's shirt yeah it's coming up he
calls his wife it's gonna be a late
night
i got a big business meeting finally i
think we played four more i won two out
of the four but
realistically i did the 17 games you
beat me 15 to two yeah that's what you
say you know
we're going to see what's going to
happen here i have a full-time trainer
former olympian ping pong played at
night from 10 or 2
i get trained by uh john stamos and
entourage yeah that's exactly pretty
much what's going on right now in the
backyard
so anyways are we ready to get into some
topics here yeah i don't know
did we are we don't address in the
elephant in the room florida we had
coveted we've been waiting to move
i think we're appreciative of all the of
all the support we've had from the
valuetaining
valuetainment community all the
valuetainers out there asking us what
the hell is going on here
by the way if you're happy we're back
smash that subscribe button if you're
happy
that this podcast is back and you would
like us to go back to doing this two
times maybe three times a week smash
that subscribe button before we move on
you gotta give a shout out to who
to our to my best friend in the world
who's that tom zenner that's right where
the [ __ ] is tom
mom is not here tom we miss you by the
way tom shout out to tom tom's doing a
great job with bt post
very very good job with vt posters
writing he's doing it and uh
thomas all the way on the west coast
california it's a challenge to make a
move like this because
kids are in school et cetera et cetera
it's not the easiest thing to make you
know a lot of times singles you move you
move but when you're moving kids you're
moving schools you're moving
relationships a lot you move friendships
but
you have no clue how hard it was for me
to move my cats your cats were going to
a private school
yeah yeah they and one thing you guys
don't know about the atom is adam was in
love with texas
adam was in love with might have stayed
just for the night life of texas there
was a very special connection you have
with the nightlife
in in texas versus miami true obviously
they don't compete together at all and
dallas's nightlife is here miami's
alice nightlife is the best in the world
you know so
incredible it was tough but shout out to
tom zenner um
he'll be back uh yeah popping in every
once in a while we're gonna have
other guests here as well schedule is
being set up we're gonna have some of
the
uh older uh friends coming back you're
gonna see danielle you're gonna see
udell you're gonna see a whole new slew
of people that want to get on the lineup
because we're in florida biz doc
this doc wants to make a comeback he's
not gonna make a comeback he says i
watched the last podcast
i'm coming to go to war against adam but
that's what's gonna happen
yeah exactly and uh exactly i know so
anyways
let me let me give one last thing give
it to us to make this round circle
all come together you said that you went
to the breakers and you said all right
you and jen
you fell in love with florida yeah 40
years ago
today my parents went to the breakers
and they fell in love and that's where i
was conceived and
now 41 years later it is my birthday
and it all has come full circle at the
breakers it all goes down and i
never been to the breakers since it's
brilliant do you realize rule of thumb
you don't do your birthday i do your
birthday okay
that's what is that all about i'm just
saying i'm bringing it up bring
it bring it what are you doing he
couldn't wait can you go grab he's
talking about
are you freaking kidding me i'm sorry i
didn't bring it in
that's like a throw-in i'm supposed to
enough love are you not getting enough
attention at home
you bring a mariachi let me tell you no
let me tell you what mariachi guys from
dallas wouldn't show up but we got you a
couple different unique things here if
you got it
we got some soy milk i think it's
appropriate for all of us to have a shot
of soy milk
this is for you this is should i chug
this i might just on behalf of the
entire crew
do we have the rest of the stuff okay
it's going to be here in a minute
freaking adam couldn't even wait this
happened i didn't
i didn't know you really you know i just
want to talk about dinner
not the right time guys i'm out of here
today like
you know my apologies killing me here
i'm not even trying to i was talking to
talking no you're breakers
you want about the breakers okay all
right fair enough you want you talk
about breakers do you have it or you
don't have it sam if we don't have it
we'll wait it's okay
don't worry about it let's just cake and
balloons guys adam already announces
bert that we want to
we want to get his cake and balloons no
we don't need any cake and balloons okay
well while you're but shout out to doug
he gave five bucks at the soy boy mafia
i appreciate it birthdays
uh we had a guy here adam said yeah gave
thirty-five minutes to pbs search online
for the unsuccessful
okay hang on there we go happy birthday
to you oh my god
birthday to you guys three one two three
happy birthday to you
happy
[Applause]
feels great feels great i couldn't ask
for a better birthday present to be
one-on-one with pbd on our first podcast
it feels very great
and i got my soy boy protein over here
i'm gonna chug this up we're gonna get
hammered on your swim we're gonna take
shots
happy birthday items send him some love
send him some love
okay there you go okay we can move this
no no no leave it man it's appropriate
it's got to stay
i want to make sure you know the entire
time we appreciate you okay i want this
thing to stay right here
love you buddy thank you we love you too
bro 100 the entire team i didn't mean to
ruin the surprise here
it's all good bro we we we knew it's
your birthday i wanted to just move on
we're going to go to lunch today we're
going to do dinner you're going to be
cheated today
buddy come on guys thank you guys and
kosher too
yeah it freaking better be so are we
ready
we're ready let's get into it okay paul
mario we're going to come to you for
advice as well and council as well and
feedback we're going to need to be ready
to give you something i'm ready
i know mario's done i've been training
all night mario's done a lot of research
last night okay all right so first of
all adam said adam bray said shout out
to pbd uh he gave 35 dollars i have
researched online but have been
unsuccessful
can you please post the link to the
greatest general in history story that
you're referencing
you know honestly the book is a small
book that john maxwell has it's a blue
book from like 20 years ago adam can you
do me a favor
send me a message on instagram and if i
don't respond back send it again two or
three times so comes up
and i'll personally go try to look for
it and send it to you
and i'll send a link to you from amazon
send that message to me i'll try to find
it for you
and then adam you're just getting a
bunch of love from everybody
you know if you love adam and you you
want to give me a shout out to you know
i'll put the link below for his
instagram account go give him one of our
friends said happy soy boy day that's
great seriously i mean this is they got
to make it official here in florida
okay so from the last time we spoke yes
sir until today
[Music]
capital that's insurrection craziness we
have
joe biden is no longer president elect
he's our president he's the guy he is
the president i know you have a nice
painting of him on the wall so he's the
president
uh from that moment till today jack ma
resurfaced okay he
went away yeah he resurfaced retrained
re-educated game stop
you know wall street bets you know they
went up against you know
wall street and it wasn't pretty you
know melbourne capital lost a lot of
money
seth's going on those guys have to give
them 2.75 billion dollars and bail them
out and
it's just not a pretty situation that
took place right
and then trump's getting impeached
second time from last time to this time
biden's cabinet's official
janet yellen is the first female
treasury secretary
it's in it's locked in pete budachich is
the
first openly gay cabinet confirmed me
and youngest transportation secretary
in history all of this stuff has
happened in the last four weeks
some of it is old story we don't need to
really talk about it some of it will
cover right now as well
but let's go to a couple different
stories that we have going on right now
that's maybe business and then we'll go
into some of the other political stories
sports we'll cover all of it so first
one i think we ought to get into is uber
uber agrees to buy alcohol delivery
service
drizzly for 1.1 billion okay 1.1 billion
dollars
uber agrees to buy them founded in 2012
drizzly has become the leading on-demand
alcohol delivery service in u.s and is
available in 1400 cities
the purchase could help drive people to
see uber's app more often uber eats
has been a key segment to uber's
business and the cover 19 pandemic which
has dramatically reduced
the number of people leaving their homes
during this time during this time
our business has been uh seen growth
extraordinary rates uber co dara said on
cnbc
drizzly said it had more than 300 growth
uh
this past year the deal is expected to
close within the first half of 2021 uber
said it anticipates that more than 90
of the consideration to be paid to
drizzly shareholders will consist of
shares of uber common stock and the
balance will be in cash
so a 90 10 split is what they're doing
at the same time uber has uh offloaded
some of its
uh more cost-eating transportation
segments the company last may
transferred its electric bike and
scooter business jumped to lime
uber also sold itself driving unit
advanced technology group to its startup
competitors
aurora innovation on december 7th at a
valuation of 4 billion at the same time
so what are your thoughts about this
drizzly and 1.1 billion dollar
purchased by uber so yeah this is i'm
glad that you started with this so
if there's anybody that can speak about
the advantages of using uber it's the
guy that hasn't had a car in for
10 years so well right now i'm
carpooling with my mom for the next week
until i move into my apartment shout out
to your mom
coolest mom out there she's cool she's
cool she's groovy i feel like i'm 17
years old again you know carpooling my
mom
um but i uber everywhere and let's talk
about what uber is focusing on and what
uber is
basically deleting from their um
focus so you got uber by the way we
tried to take an uber
package the other day people are coming
in town we need to give them their keys
yeah
seven people who work at valuetainment
couldn't figure out how to order an uber
package so in uber here's what you have
you can take an uber all right i need to
go
to my friend's house i'm taking an uber
you can go uber eats right
you want to order in food you're staying
in everyone's there in covid you're
ordering in
you got uber packages hey uh clarissa
leo they just got in town we got to give
them their keys send them the keys in a
package you don't have to go drive over
there
wink wink at mario they'll send them the
package that's easy
they got uber groceries so they're
competing with the insta carts of the
world and now
they're basically saying look we got
liquor too so they're basically
saying listen work at home eat at home
drink at home
party at home everywhere you need to go
just
we got you uber what do they not have
thank you buddy move that move that out
of there thank you
it was cutting mario's head off there we
want to make sure we got to see mario
this is actually pretty interesting they
stopped their e-bike
um focus their they stopped their
self-driving component yep
and this i had to reread this like three
times the flying
taxi unit what the hell is that
they were they they announced it was
selling their flying
taxi business called elevate was that
was that is that am i reading that
correctly flying cars
yeah what is this back to the future
this is gonna happen i mean what do you
think's gonna end up happening i mean i
don't know i feel like elon musk is
gonna take over that business who knows
what that but
this just this move with drizzly
specifically for a billion bucks 90
shares 10 cash makes complete sense with
their focus of you know staying at home
ordering in
ordering packages getting your liquor so
that's my taking what are your thoughts
so first of all just so you know during
the pandemic
at the peak of the pandemic in april do
you know how much
the sales of drizzly was up do you guys
know what do you what do you think it
was up during
april may how high do you think their
stock went up
sales coming in sales is coming in
percentage-wise or
percentage-wise 135
700 to 800 percent they took the under
it's how high they were so explain that
why do you think that leveled around
350.
350 for the rest of the year pretty much
and you heard you know in this article
i'm reading it says
you know they've seen growth of you know
growth of 300 et cetera et cetera
so why well people stayed home and they
had drinks they're depressed let me get
a drink let me get a second one let me
get a third one and i'm boom let me
order let me order let me order
easy access you know i can just go get
it it's going to come to me and uh
so you know that showed what direction
potentially the world is going to so
uber's sitting there saying wait if
people are ordering liquor the way they
are right now why don't we own that
business
are they assuming there's going to be
another pandemic are they assuming it's
going to be more work from home are they
assuming this the direction that things
going to go
yeah working from home et cetera i don't
know uh but they definitely made the
right move this is a very very smart
strategic
uh purchase that they made and i think
this is going to be
benefiting uber uh in a big way
for a very long time this isn't going to
be a small business here
this 1.1 billion dollar business that
they bought
look at this 1.1 billion dollar business
how quickly it's gonna end up being a 20
30 billion dollar business oh you think
so oh
buddy you know listen alcohol
ain't going away you know breakups are
not going away depression is not going
away people being
celebration bad celebration down
birthdays birthdays it's not going away
we're trying to convert people to
drinking soy yes
but drizzly look for my new line of soy
based alcohol that's coming out
it'll be on the valuetainment shop check
that out at valuetainmentstore.com what
paul do you have any opinions on drizzly
let's see what paul wants to say about
drizzly
i do i do think it's a good idea um
anything deep tell us outside of a good
idea do you have any deep thoughts on
this topic
i do think it's a good idea guys that's
paul's cards
i don't think i have anything deep on
drizzly it's not a you tell me
you've been prepared they're maximizing
you just had your moment right there
here's the freaking bottom line you have
the choice of ordering liquor
into your house the couch or going to
the freaking gecko we all know where
you're going you're going to the bar
you're going to get go you're not a stay
at home and drink kind of yeah look
you go hit the streets i think it all
depends on what state you're living in i
think in certain states it's really
going to have a huge impact
like places like florida and texas where
places are open
i don't see it having as much of an
impact versus california where
everything's closed yeah i could see
that having a huge impact or if you're
up north in the winter if you're in new
york
minnesota if it's connecticut yeah i
like that that's a good one you went
deep you went
good for you all right so parlor ceo
fired by the board
oh uh parlor has terminated ceo john
matsey according to
uh meme mart's uh memo mart sent to
staffers that has been obtained by fox
news on january 29 2021 departed board
controlled by rebecca
mercer decided to immediately terminate
my position as ceo of parliament i did
not participate in this decision
i understand that those who now control
the company have some
communication to employees and other
third parties that have unfortunately
created
confusion improvement prompted me to
make this public statement matsy wrote
that over the past few months he has
been met constant resistance to his
original
vision for the social media platform
following amazon web services decision
to shut parlor down for failure to
moderate
agree egregious content related to the
january six capital rights
thoughts yeah you know i'm going to
bring up a couple points here and then
really i want to get your take on this
because you're a ceo of a company a
founder of a company
i want to get your opinion on this you
know how old this guy is
the founder of parlor late 30s he's 27
28 years old that's pretty impressive
very okay
28 years old you're the ceo of parlor
how much you think this guy's worth
well at the peak or at the low
right now i don't know i checked his
network i don't think it's an accurate
network you read really
there's no way the net worth is accurate
his net worth collapsed probably 70 80
in the last 90 days so one thing has
gone down in the last night
what did it say's net worth is 10
million bucks
okay now he's he's probably worth you
know a number like that because the
company went all the way up to
you know 750 750 million dollar company
is it a public traded company no no no
i i don't know if it's actually all i'm
saying is as far as the way they were
valuing their company was around being
half a billion to a billion dollar
company wow
so from that to the drop off it's a
completely different story but what do
you think about them
firing him listen you're the ceo of a
company you're a founder of a company
right i mean all i've ever been is a vp
of sales at a company i've never founded
a company
what does that entail when you found a
company
you're the ceo i assume that you have a
major hand in
selecting the board members yeah and
then they say hey buddy pat
hit the road what does that feel like oh
so
that means he doesn't have control of
the board that means
they own more shares of the company
potentially than he does so it's not
like he
is the founder the ceo that means he
raised money
uh to the point where matter of fact let
me look at crunch base can you look at
mario pull up crunch bass and type in
parlor
go to crunch bass crunch bass and then
type in parlor and partners with an
e you think it's with an o but it's with
an e parlor
uh let's see how much money they've
raised parlor do you see it
okay type in parlor he just told you it
was with an e
uh mario did he do oh yeah he went oh
okay
there you go kai was texting me okay so
go to click on parlo right there
i'd go up a little bit go up the other
way yeah yeah
founder 2018 angel okay keep going up
up up what so they haven't raised money
wait that okay number of investors two
highlights click on that
to the right right there uh rebecca
mercer
angel angel okay click on robert mercer
see how much he gave
are they disclosing it or no go up go up
robert mercer it says undisclosed amount
right okay undisclosed
then go to the next one go back and see
if we can find that if rebecca's
number's public interesting why would
you make it undisclosed
uh and this is also undisclosed they're
not saying it
same thing okay okay walk us what you
just did here okay so
okay so go go to another company go to
robin hood okay type in robinhood
crunch base tells you the the raising of
money the organization details about
like right there look if i want to find
out robin on how much money they've
raised
click on total funding amount right
there and then it tells you every time
they raise money so go down the first
time they raise money
all the way down to the first round they
raise to show okay so you have to have
the
the free trial okay they raised 323
million dollars a year and a half ago
july 22nd
series e so e means d c
b a four rounds prior to ironically
enough two days ago three days ago they
they had their 2.4 billion dollars 2.4
billion dollars four billion
in the middle of the whole game so then
if you want to find out who it was click
on the number six
click on uh convertible node robinhood
right there let's see who was the people
that were involved
it's big names it's not small names
sequoia capital ribbit
new enterprise associates index venture
i mean they got
and recent horowitz i mean they got the
main guys that are putting money with
them
six investors came in put 2.4 billion
dollars so
partner middle of all that but listen
all of this stuff that people are saying
with robin hood
yeah look you can say all you want about
robin hood you can say anything you want
about robin take shots at them all you
want last thursday they had 175
000 new people that downloaded their app
and last thursday they had more people
using robinhood
than all the other brokerage accounts
combined me put this again
last thursday after all this heat after
all this being trashed by
aoc musk everybody that trashed them
right
last thursday they had more people on
their app than anybody
else all their competition combined
right let's name the competition who
they're competing he trades short trade
scots trades
vanguard all of them so robin hood is
bigger than all these guys now not now i
didn't say bigger
traffic more people remember it's a free
platform so
the market is not the market of higher
echelon you know it's more
500 i'm going to buy one stock i'm going
to buy 10 seconds they're not quantity
not quality
quantity and now maybe some quality
they're they're starting to get quality
they're not going to just stay quantity
for too long you start off with
quantities robinhood is no joke at this
point
robinhood is a 25 to 30 billion auto
companies are these big guys these
schwabs these e-trades these
scottrade these vanguards fidelities
they got to be a little bit nervous with
this new guy
let's let's stay on parlor and we'll go
to that here in a minute so on parlor
let's talk about parliament i don't know
how much those guys bought from the
company i don't
know when somebody comes in and they
give you money the next step after
agreeing to give money
guess what's the next thing that's
talked about control controls
what controls i have so what is controls
your salary
your bonus uh how much money you can
spend without without our approval
if you want to make uh spend a hundred
thousand dollars you don't need to
approve if you're spending a penny above
a hundred thousand dollars you need to
get to approval
that can be a quarter million a half a
million and that can go up as the
company's grown and you're doing a
better job
the controls could be what other things
you can do outside the controls could be
a lot of different things when you're
raising money right with the company
i don't know the controls of this guy i
have no idea i don't know how he set
himself up if he's 27 28
he could be smart he could be brilliant
but he's not that experienced to know
what controls matter and what controls
don't matter when he
you hear the saying when a man with
money
meets a man with experience the man
with experience leaves with the money
right the man with the money leaves with
the experience
he just left with the experience wow
okay profound that's literally exactly
exactly what just happened he just left
with experience so now
they're firing him what the hell does
that mean you're firing him
does this mean you have somebody in mind
that you're gonna recruit
that's gonna be able to get the web
services up and parlor's gonna be back
up
so for some of the people that are part
of like
pro parlor community this could be a
good thing because if the board is
firing him
maybe they think if they bring somebody
from a google maybe they think if they
bring somebody from another company to
make the company be more independent
right in the middle
maybe they bring a former executive from
amazon to bring
maybe they think that connection is
going to get amazon to say fine we'll go
because the person that's now running
the company is a former executive of
amazon or whatever
now we feel a little bit more
comfortable i don't know but if you do
make a public firing of a ceo
you do not look good if you don't have a
plan afterwards
i don't that makes sense or not of
course if you just fired me you better
have a plan so if within the next week
parlor's board doesn't have a new guy
gal leader that's going to be running it
that starts showing progress
what was your point about firing the guy
what statement did you want to make
like what was the motive parlor's down
nobody's downloading the app
they don't have aws all the other web
services don't want to give them the
business
they keep saying oh we're going to come
out with a new website oh something's
going on something
if you don't have a replacement you're
going to look like a fool
yourself so the board's about to look
like a fool if they don't come out with
a replacement this is not just him
looking bad the board's also going to
look bad if they don't bring somebody
that's going to make the company go back
to being let me ask you a question on
that do you think that companies are
being put in a position to maybe
a pressure position to make these type
of decisions to make the masses
maybe feel better about their company
how do you think they're processing
decisions like this because a lot of it
has been happening the last few weeks
on decisions being made that are made by
others so so that's a great question so
this leads to robin hood right your time
on robinhood so
what does the name robinhood mean what
does the name robinhood mean
from the rich gift of the reporters
steal from the government remember
remember robin hood
cartoon was never steal from the rich
it was steal from the tax stealer which
is the government
people get this confused they think it's
stealing from the rich the rich
was the government right that's what it
meant so it's not steel from the rich
the rich creates
jobs the government who forces tax
on you is who they want robin hood
wanted to get money back from
not the small business owners that were
selling bread and but robin had never
went and tried to take money away from
the people that are creating small
businesses
right that wasn't the idea robin hood
was trying to take money back from who
the big government that's bullying the
average guy that doesn't have any
control because of regulation right okay
people imposing taxes yeah so robinhood
started off as a great idea
it was purely accidental it went from
what it was i mean you did a great video
on it yourself just a couple days ago
it went from what it was hey this is for
average investors you're not gonna have
to pay anything just come over here and
get out you know do your trades
beautiful story and it grew and it got
the attention of a lot of different
people
lots of big names lots of hollywood
people lots of celebrities you keep
seeing videos and advertisement from
these guys
that keep doing their thing but
eventually
when you raise 2.4 billion
your boss is no longer the customer your
boss officially changed
when all of a sudden you go from your
customer
is middle america but your owners
is wall street you're conflicted oh yeah
big time
big time so who are you loyal to now who
do you have to listen to now
who can fire you now who can say you
know you got to get out of here now
you're sitting there saying well these
guys this company is at 30 billion
dollars my net worth is now xyz
what do i do how do i keep them happy
how do i keep the consumer happy but i
got to make sure these guys are happy
when they said when he shut down and
said no trading all like you're talking
about vlad
yeah i mean you think people are naive
when elon musk is asking those questions
on uh
club um clubhouse clubhouse and he's
just grilling him 16 minutes
and going back and forth i mean you you
don't think people are naive that what
happened there
but it's not the point the board the
founder starts with a
vision and the vision is here's what
we're doing this company for
the board the buyer of the company when
they come in and they're like listen we
love your vision
keep driving the company but we like
profits
that's what we like okay so if you want
to focus on profits this so
the relationship between those two has
to be set up in a way
where the vision and the cause doesn't
change if the vision and the cause
changes you could potentially lose your
customers that you already had although
that's not happening in robin hood
but today you're living in a different
time you're living in a time right now
where you're seeing a
parlor you're seeing a robin hood two
different stories parlor founders uh
maybe the guy that came out saying we
gotta go against facebook we gotta go
because
freedom of speech we have to have people
to be able to say whatever they wanna
say because that was his message right
that's what we're gonna do
but the money guys are like listen
that's great we just gave you 10 million
bucks
we just gave you 50 million bucks i'm
sorry give us our 50 million dollars
back i don't have that kind of money
now we're changing it so to changes we
have to bring somebody that's going to
be a little bit more
reasonable a little bit more there
someone who probably gets along with big
tech a little bit better
you kind of have to do that right today
you kind of have to do you got to follow
the laws today
on the social side because so one day i
had a group of people in my office and i
wrote a map
i said uh the democrats are brilliant
dude they're so brilliant
and i was having this conversation last
week i think with robert kiyosaki i
think it was i know who it was
somebody was having this conversation
last week yeah and i said
republicans chased money
democrats chased influence and control
period let me say that one more time
yeah republicans chase money which was
what man let me just make money and
leave me alone
okay so traditional business that you go
to
that you don't have influence but
traditional business day you're talking
about politically or actual
independent like voters i'm talking
politically okay
and power player billionaires that's
what i'm talking about
democrats said no we have to control
voice
so what did democrats billionaires start
buying l.a times
new york times washington post time
magazine
et cetera et cetera right then what do
they do amazon web services
now it's the biggest they're killing it
what they're doing amazon
facebook google you know
twitter go through all of them doors
all of these guys for republicans now to
compete
on the media side you know how long it's
going to take for them to compete in the
media site
decade two decades not one decade no way
two media side on the media side it's
going to take
two decades for them to even have a shot
and by the way
two decades from now you think it'll be
50 50 even no way
two decades from now it will still only
be 70 30.
where do you think it is now oh i think
it's 98 to 2 right now that that
that big give me on the right what the
media has one channel yeah they got fox
you got newsmax you got newsmax is not
newsmax it's not
at the level you don't put those guys at
that level yet as far as an nbc you do
not put them at that level
by the way if you look at right now it's
msnbc it's cnn it's fox then you got cbs
abc you know
all those other guys are all on on the
left they're not on the right so
so this is a little bit more of a
long-term
strategy that you know folks got to sit
down and kind of think about on what's
taking place you can't just sit there
and say
let me tell you this is not fair and
this is not this no it's not called not
fair it's called competition
and it's called you know some of the
strategies that you had republicans on
your side kind of didn't help you out
and if you don't start making some
changes right now you're going to have
to
behoove and you're going to have to bow
down to whatever
they have to tell you because they
control that's
just what's going on period so
there there needs to be a major like you
know i'm on a flight back with a guy
uh jerry i'm trying to sleep because i
had three hours of sleep that day that
was award ceremony i'm trying couple
days ago a couple days ago but jerry's
got great stories
phenomenal stories and he's telling me
you know 1967 he started working for
bell and back in the days when
a you know a tnt had a what do you call
it a um
monopoly because at t pretty much
control the market and the government
had to come in and break up at t
because you could only buy phone system
from one place so att would come in and
they would say hey
you know you got three plans which one
do you want i don't like any of these no
problem
okay cool good luck so can you imagine
there is nobody else that's coming to
your house afterwards so the government
said you can't do this so they broke
them apart
then they became different companies
anyways he finally said he said you know
what's the one thing about democrats
against republicans he said what
he says republicans compete against each
other democrats
unify even if they hate each other you
have to give them
credit they are united even if they hate
each other
there is more going on today with all
these businesses parlor robin hood
it's it's more political than people
even realize today this is no longer
about just doing business today
it's not it's a completely different
game so 27 28 year old that's going in
yeah and and you know the zucks of the
world who started facebook
zuck's brain is also a different kind of
a brain it's not a regular brain it's
you know in the gates brain and the jobs
young brain
those brains are wired in a different
way to compete
nowadays you you need to be ready and
you need to have influence from many
different places
especially in the social media game let
me uh something that's on my mind since
we're going to go back to the parlor ceo
he's 28 years old
zuk's probably in his late 30s now um
[Music]
you said a quote uh a little bit ago you
said
show me two people the man with money
meets a man with experience the man with
the experience walks away with the money
the man with the money walks with
you know we have an audience who are in
their 20s 30s 40s what have you
um give us you founded php
you were how old 30 31 okay 31 but
up until that point you were you were a
big dog at your former company i was
doing good okay
you're now 42 years old 42. walk us
through pbd
founder ceo 30 years old yeah first
pbd ceo founder 40 years old and use
that analogy between money and
experience because now you have both
back then you had little right you had
some money
some experience yeah if pbd one who's 30
meets pvd when he's 42
what happens well well let me ask you a
question trump's 74 when he becomes
72-71 when he becomes president
does he have a lot of experience of
course does he have a lot of money yeah
sure
does he have as much experience in
politics as politicians have experienced
in politics
probably not it doesn't matter how much
experience you got in business
or in wealth that you have if you go
into a field that you don't have
experience in you will get schooled
gotcha experience and money like
experience in one place
doesn't mean that that experience bleeds
into every other thing that you do
right you and so what happens when you
do that
the biggest thing that changed from the
31-year pbd to 42 euro pbd is asking
council
and then processing for myself so hey i
don't have all the answers
31 year old i have all the answers you
42 year old you know hey what do you
think what happened here what happened
what should we do here what do you think
about this
so it's a little bit more of asking for
counsel then i know exactly what i'm
doing by the way both is needed because
you need a little bit of i know what i'm
doing we're going to go take over the
world
you need that drive and the fire to go
out there right that level of
determination
but the experience comes with hey we're
about to do this what do you think about
this
i would take this angle tell me why here
okay interesting let me go ask johnny
johnny what do you think bobby said this
on the board you know
so it's a little bit more wanting to get
counsel rather than i know exactly what
i'm doing
trumpkin and got got into politics
became a president did what he did four
years he said everything he said he was
going to do he did it
and then but he didn't win allies
on the left and you don't have to win a
hundred percent of them
not one percent not five percent not ten
percent you need them
especially today you need them in the
business world you do as well today
because
all this stuff about wall street bets
well wall street's bats you know here's
what they're gonna they're taking down
wall street
really what kind of context do they have
because
melbourne capital capital seth cohen
citadel citron all those guys have to do
is make 510 phone calls in dc
then they create new regulation then
they create
tougher barrier to enter then they're
able to target companies like reddit
because they have the contacts all the
way at the top which is politicians it's
a different game today
than it's ever been before it's always
been like this don't get me wrong you've
always had to have a
element of this but today you got to be
ready to compete in the next level
so you're saying that the wall street
bets reddit community are not as
powerful as they're somehow
being made out to be because i'll give
you a quote you know uh chamath
palapatiya yeah very smart guy
potentially running for governor of
california he's out there he's talking
about everything you know he said things
like let the big airlines fail companies
fail
i agree he said oh you do because we
could talk about that if you don't you
did a full agreement you did a four
elements of capitalism episode
you agree with that freedom to fail you
talked about that freedom to buy freedom
to try freedom for self freedom to fail
freedom to fail yeah
uh he says wall street bets is now
officially the number one hedge fund
in the world because they are a
democratized and decentralized
platform and this is his opinion
obviously but i don't disagree with that
okay i everything what you just said i
don't disagree with that
but here's the here's the issue yeah who
who was the
most famous people in the world four
months ago
most famous person in the world powerful
person in the world four months ago
well maybe trump was four months ago
four months ago yeah what happened to
him
goodbye what happened to his twitter
account what happened to his facebook
kickout peace out when's the last time
you said
let me check on trump's tweet here's
what trump said when's the last time
you're the best two months of my life by
the way you know what's crazy
not for cnn they're down 44.
yes yes viewership for the last 40 days
in the last 30 days that's a scary
thought 30 days that's a long time for
businesses
tweet something what are you going to do
joe biden's the greatest of all time no
one cares yeah
people want anima people want media's
that right so they're now taking a hit
msnbc is taking a hit they're firing
people they're letting go of people
they're trying to get into market for
somebody to buy them they don't have
money cnn
they can't sustain this for too long
that's what bezos was talking about
buying cnn
yeah this is not sustainable long-term
so
yes so you're saying that you wish that
they wish they had still had trump as a
product because obviously cnn has done
everything in their power to get trump
the hell out of office now you think
that they're sort of regretting that
decision for
ratings purposes for money purposes what
was your question when you started your
your question you were asking we were
talking about wall street bets and
influence and power yeah you got the
melvin capitals so what i'm trying to
tell you is
if if the government can team up against
trump and take him down who the hell is
wall street bets
yeah okay who's wall street bets you
know 7.2 million subscribers
by the way for me you need
a trump you need a wall street bets
you need an aoc a check on the other
side
you need all of this when you eliminate
and you make the other powerful the
other also becomes weaker
you need all of these guys right just
like you need a strong republican party
to compete with the democrats you
need socialism you need it just like you
need a strong democratic party to come
out with you yes you do
it's a i think you need an obama you
need a you know you need you need
a trump you need a ted cruz you need a
pull you need some of that now trying to
unify these guys today little
like i wouldn't mind seeing them 20
percent come a little bit more
center 20 come a little bit both sides
oh yeah 20 right come to the left a
little bit let me come to the right a
little bit you know a little bit more
in midfield by the way you know the
whole uh uh executive orders
yeah biden okay do you want to pull that
up do you know who has who has
who ha you've seen this already the set
i'm assuming right mario
bring it up before we bring it up let me
just kind of read this let me just kind
of read this if we're gonna go political
here pat i gotta do one thing first you
gotta go to the bathroom no i gotta get
a little sewing my cup okay
this guy's gonna go to the bathroom i
swear we're done
oh my god okay so so so take a look at
this take a look at this
so our buddy biden becomes president
right when he becomes president he goes
on a
executive order frenzy right big time
and he said in an interview i think it
was last year when they asked him they
said
what do you think about executive orders
he said i think executive orders
if you do it without asking the other
side you're a dictator what's the
difference between a dictator and
someone so this is
he says this in an interview you can see
this it's everything
less than a year ago wow that's what it
was right give or take a year ago
so he becomes a president day one
executive order paris climate change
ending ban on u.s entry from majority
muslim countries
requiring mass wearing on federal
property coordinating a a
government-wide
covenanting response incorporating the
undocumented immigrants into
senses refusing refocusing on climate
crisis and canceling the keystone
keystone
xl permit which was massive mandating
ethics
ethics pledge for government appointees
polling funds
from border wall pausing federal student
loan payments
strengthening deferred action for
childhood arrivals
promoting covet 19 safety and domestic
and international travel
expanding access to cover 19 treatments
established in a cover 19 pandemic
testing board
guaranteeing unemployment insurance for
workers who refuse work due to covet 19
facilitating delivery for stimulus
payments empowering
federal workers and contractors
okay reversing transgender military ban
reinstating coven 19 travel restrictions
promoting buy america agenda and
reliance on private prisons
initiating plan to combat climate change
by the way i'm not done re-establishing
presidential council on science and
technology we've got like 10 pages i i i
mean i can keep going you know
reinforce and medicaid and affordable
health care act okay 35 executive orders
seven memorandums and three
proclamations and if you pull up the
history of who's had
the most executive orders this is what
you would find okay go up
so here's the leaders in executive
orders
biden okay go up a little bit so i can
read exactly what the timeline biden's
fury
flurry of executive order standouts in
his first two weeks president biden has
signed more executive orders
uh uh most recent presidents did in
their first month he has signed nearly
as many executive orders as fdr did in
his record-breaking month so
fdr did 30 biden the 28.
look who's third obama is third at what
16.
you take trump out who's fourth true
truman now watch this why did i say if
you take trump out here's why
the left typically likes to enforce
through force
we're doing this whether you like it or
not it's the left right the right wants
to uh
which true truman was a democrat yes now
watch this now watch this now watch this
trump is at 12. what does that say about
trump trump's not a republican
people don't realize trump was never a
republican
trump is independent trump was a
democrat for most of his career
now he's a republican for the last
however long decade of his career
trump stole the 12 executive orders that
is an independent you look at the rest
bush seven clinton six
ghw bush senior two he was just
like i'm not even having any executive
orders in the first 30 days reagan five
carter left seven ford five
on the right nixon five on the right
johnson left
seven kennedy left seven eisenhower
right six truman left 13. this tells you
about how they look at executive order
so what does this have to do what we
were talking about earlier
with uh uh with what do you call it with
uh wall street bets
if um if the right people want to just
go out and create a new law
and push wall street bets around they
can easily do it
you know why most of these guys on the
left were funded by wall street
so if you get funded by wall street you
have to kind of realize just like the
company we talk about
robin hood which is what you campaign
for the little person the small people
the people that don't have the money but
you report to who
the people that people gave you big
money of course wall street people they
give you the big money
these there's no no difference here you
you campaign we got to help the
but you have to report to the people
that funded your campaign
and if you don't make that phone call
and the campaign people call you and say
hey listen we gave you this much money
here's what you need to do here we need
a law
we need barrier to enter papa papa we
need somebody to go look at wall street
vets and investigate them we need
somebody
that's how this thing works i am fully
on wall street's bedside i'd like 100
percent
what do you mean of course 100
but you need contacts so hopefully these
shamats and musks and all these other
guys are so on their side that they
protect them
hopefully that's what they need right
that's basically come out and said that
he's on this
on this team and he donated uh yeah
yeah so with with uh i mean i don't know
how much time you want to spend on
biden's
exactly we have like 12 pages go forward
go forward you know i went through
some of these and let me give you
i guess my perspective on this i went uh
there's probably four pages i don't
disagree with a lot of these things
yeah you know so let me give you two
sides of the coin here on biden
number one he came out there and he said
what's the quote that you said if you do
too many executives you're dictating
orders
you're a dictator yeah at the same time
he's just reversing a lot of what trump
just did so rever
trump came in reversed a lot of what
obama did obama uh uh yeah but
so many other presidents can do the same
thing totally with you but he's doing it
more than what's the other what's the
one thing in common with who
fdr when he was the president in 1933
what what are they worldwide they had a
crisis they just had a freaking they
just got out of the great depression in
the middle of the great depression now
they're in world war
ii so biden because again this is in the
first
month of the presidency right this is
what this stat is
trump came in and there wasn't a lot to
quote unquote change he did it
you know in my opinion a lot of it out
of spite a lot of it of like
well obama did this i'm doing this yeah
biden is coming in a lot of his mask
mandates
you know executive orders on climate
crisis
you know obviously he's no fan of big uh
big oil um
a lot of it is covered related exactly
the other side won't you ask the other
side well that's the my next point trust
the other side why don't you just say
hey guys if it's not that big of a deal
won't you ask him
i don't know how that works within
congress but yes his whole it's not a
big deal why don't you ask him and sit
down guys here's what i wonder what do
you think about it yeah
and let them say we disagree okay i'm
going to do it anyways how long does
that take though
because this this political politically
it could take weeks so so
years to get something done let's get it
done listen for me
here's here's like my approach you know
tico and dylan get into it okay did you
guys try to address it with each other
no i don't want to talk to them i can't
help you
talk to each other yeah get in a room
and figure it out then come out and
still do the executive order i'm good
because now you can say what look i went
in the room and i talked to them
we tried to talk about they didn't want
to talk to me yeah okay cool the people
gonna say
you know what fine but you at least made
what
the effort that hey here's where we are
this is what i want to do you know you
can't
drop the word unity and not do that so
for example if your campaign jimmy
carter's campaign was what
human rights okay and he targeted two
countries
iran and cuba okay human rights late 70s
late 70s human rights human rights if
that's your campaign
you better advance that campaign trump's
campaign was what
build the wall build the wall build the
wall build the wall make but it was
build a wall
build the wall build the wall guess what
he started building the wall
right that's what i need to do taxes
build a wall etcetera
he said what he's going to do great if
you say unify you got to unify
you but so then don't say unify
obama said what change change to what
change of philosophy change of what
obamacare health care
guess what he kept his commitment
of i'm going to go out there make change
now he got up and said it's not going to
cost you
a penny we're not going to tax you can
keep your plan if you're watching that
was not the truth
it wasn't a true but he did make drastic
changes
scary changes for some people on the
other side but he kept his commitment
you can't say unify is that basically
your point here on biden is that you
saying let's i'm going to be the
president for all these people
we're known as the centrist you're the
centrist you're let's just say you're a
center left guy etc
okay great show a little bit now he's
coming in as a dictator now he's
essentially
he's coming in on what he called the
dictator not what i call a dictator
his interpretation of a dictator i never
said he's a dictator
he said he's a dictator that's what
biden called him is it the fact that
um you don't agree with some of the
executive actions or just the fact that
he's making executive actions
regardless of what the uh actions are
you understand my question is it
i just don't like that he's doing
executive actions or i don't like
exactly what they are now listen there's
a little bit of book
if trump came out and says i'm gonna do
all executive orders
and you do well you said you were going
to do that yeah
so just you said you're going to do that
then do that it's all good
we knew he was going to do that so the
people who voted for him guess what they
wanted
a bunch of what executive order and he
did it
this guy didn't come out saying i'm
going to do a bunch of executive orders
gotcha okay
he did say a couple but he didn't come
out saying like he said climate you know
day one i'm going to do periscope
minimum wage he did say those things
totally fine yes but this many little
bit a little bit it's aggressive it's a
little aggressive on what's aggressive
so
again the the the parlor the robin hood
the
the the amount of executive orders
somehow someway they're all tied to each
other
this is all tied to each other somehow
some way okay let's go into the next one
let's go and talk about amazon okay
amazon jeff bezos decides to step down
as a ceo so
jazzy is his replacement andy jazzy
jazzy joined amazon in 1997 the euro one
public and quickly moved up the ranks
he's a close confidant of bezos and has
led amazon cloud computing
business since 2003 the cloud ceo helped
built aws into a massive unit that
generates over 40 billion dollars in
annual revenue aws is also the de facto
leader in cloud computing
by the way for we just talked about
40 billion dollars in annual
revenue okay exactly de facto leader in
cloud computing
over 30 percent of market share is
officially aws
adam over 30 percent is officially aws
insiders say bezos undoubtedly unbounded
uh trust in jazzy who was promoted to
aws the senior vice president to ceo in
2016.
the people who have worked with jazzy
who turned 53 last month described them
as genuinely united nice person who
nevertheless sets
high standards and expectation for his
people and expects them to rise to the
challenge
as he takes aws service role in powering
so much of the internet economy and his
role in keeping it to the top
in the cloud market very seriously so
andy
jassy nucio amazon and
uh bezos moves to be an executive
chairman of the board what are your
thoughts about this
i mean just the names alone if you're a
90s guy you're going to appreciate this
reference because i know you'll
appreciate this
i'm hearing jeff bezos and andy jazzy
all i'm thinking of is like
dj jazzy jeff and the fresh prince and
will smith
hillary and jeff bezos being well smith
and andy jazzy coming in as dj jazzy
jeff
playing the ones that's a scary thought
right yeah there he is that's a scary
thought but
what do you think about this what do you
think about any thoughts on this well a
couple different things
so number one first and foremost let's
start with the top let's start with this
founder let's start with the ceo
what's bezos going to be doing what's
bazel's next
five moves what's his new moves are
going to be um
it says there bezos still says he'll
still be involved
in important initiatives i don't think
bezos is just retiring and just going to
kind of go live in
san tropez and eat you know 40 euro
lobster rules in monaco somebody tells
me he's going to be working doing his
thing taking on important initiatives
part of that is going to be philanthropy
i mean don't forget his wife mackenzie
bezos who's like
the 20th richest person in the world
just because she has amazon
she's become famous why over the
pandemic for giving billions and
billions away
for philanthropic efforts cool so that's
what's going on in the basis household
yeah
and we know tom zenner was knew the
girlfriend of bezos and
somehow thomas enters in this story but
jazzy
let's talk about this guy 53 years old
uh he's going to step in as ceo when
what
q3 of 2021 you were most impressed by
the fact that what you said
40 what was it 30 of their total revenue
was aws
what was that market share market share
of cloud
today is controlled by aws is that
what's what's a monopoly 45
50 50 plus because remember iphone
smartphone is 46 percent okay so
iphone apple is 46 percent of the market
very close to being a monopoly very
you're very anti-monopoly oh it's not
good for the economy yes
at all did you play monopoly as a kid by
the way i never played monopoly as a kid
i
played many times and mario's witnessed
me playing monopoly money it's a great
game
really yeah okay speaking of pretty sure
they don't follow the rules the whole
time when it gets
late in the game what does it do does
this patch you start putting keys on the
table
it's our negotiation it's all
negotiation so if you unlock because
there's different rules you can play by
if you allow
negotiation to take place between the
two owners then it is what it is
okay so you you you don't play by the
rules you're doing some other stuff
we play by the rules okay but there are
different rules to the game of monopoly
when you play
okay what does that mean exactly the so
when you sit down and you're playing
with a group the group can
dictate the controls and the rules to
them to the game of monopoly what's that
word dictate mean in this thing right
here so
so you say hey guys what do we do when
negotiating this well we need a third
approval or not or you say there's many
different ways to play monopoly
and if the four or five if the four
players agree on the terms you agree on
the terms
okay but you do that's gotta be a great
beginning at the beginning
when everybody's at the same level you
don't create new rules at the middle of
the game
you agree on it at the beginning of the
day and we had one uh
night we were where were we at we were
in georgia we were in georgia atlanta
and it
started and it ended it was pretty epic
night i was asleep
i think it everyone did we would have
recorded that i wish we would have
recorded that but go ahead give me your
thoughts on this year
no i mean we're talking about monopolies
so they're not a monopoly level yet this
aws
right not yet okay but they're trending
in that direction they're 30 percent of
market share the weight they're growing
right now
they'll get there and this is yeah i'm
not exactly the tech
savvy guy shocker but i started hearing
more about this aws
why well let's reference back parlor
right they shut down parlor from amazon
web services
who else are they shutting down well how
much this goes back to your initial
topic
control what kind of control do they
have who's parlor going to put in as ceo
of the new company are they going to
have a good relationship with dj jazzy
jeff over here
i think he's going to be able to make a
phone call like you talked about with
melvin capital some of these guys
hey guys we got to get back up to
business we're a legitimate company
what's going on here but um
bottom line is bezos ain't going nowhere
i think i think he's going to be doing
more things like
looking into purchase cnn you know what
the question becomes
here's a few questions i'm reading a
book right now called motive by patrick
lincioni patrick lincione
if he comes out with a book you got to
read his book especially if you're in
business five dis dysfunctions of a team
five temptations of a
ceo ideal team player guy writes books
everybody needs to read it especially
in the business world so everything to
me is motive right
so whose playbook is bezos following
today he is following potentially
a bill gates playbook of non-profit
that's what i'm going to do
okay fine maybe let's just say there's a
moving forward
moving forward yes what he wants to do
the difference between him and bill
gates is what he's a little bit more
of a a flamboyant guy than gates gates
was a true qualified
nerd qualified not flamboyant at all
zero flame
bezos today looks buff he's got a chest
he's got biceps right
he changed you know when you have money
you can make yourself look any way you
want he's
like some stuff's going on over there
right okay yeah
so what is his motive i don't know what
is his motive
does he have any different aspirations
four years from now five years not ten
years from i don't know does he want to
run one day
i don't know does he want to run for
office one day i have no clue he did say
he's going to be the executive chair and
he's going to work on non-profits and
contribute to washington post
so why washington post i don't know let
me take a complete different angle here
why i love this story
here's why i love the story listen
more younger people need to be inspired
by these stories
two days after he took his final exam to
get his graduate degree
andy two days after he agreed to go to
amazon
jazzy jazzy you know what he told him
put me anywhere i don't care i'm just
happy to be here
mm-hmm and that's two that's 97 we're
talking about the rocket ship analogy
yeah it's like dude just i'm just glad
to i don't care about the rocket ship
anywhere let's go play ball right let's
go play ball so he goes in
what does he do 97 94.
amazon got started 94. he comes in at
93. young buck
young guy what do you need from me you
know and two years ago he got
interviewed on cnn
if you guys have never seen this
interview with him on cnn two years ago
the lady asks him look you've been able
to do this you've been able to do that
you've been there from day one you've
done this you've done this you've done
that
is there any aspirations of you being a
ceo you know what his answer was
he says i just can't see amazon being
ran by anybody else but jeff bezos so no
i don't have any aspects good answer
right two years later he's the ceo right
if you it's a three minute video if
you've not seen it's a great interview
to watch
it's three minutes so he's a likable guy
he's a leader to me he is following the
playbook of who
two three different names i'll give you
one is our buddy that bought the
clippers what's his name steve ballmer
balmer and he fought microsoft uh
exactly he worked his way up
under bill gates balmer paul allen tim
cook
that's the playbook he's a number two
he's a great number two but he is
about to be a very rich number two
if bezos's ex-wife became the 20th 20th
richest person in the world
he's about to become a top 100 in no
time representing a two trillion dollar
company you think they're gonna pay this
guy a few billion dollars
so what does this tell you here's what
it tells you listen let's talk a little
bit of business let's talk a little bit
of business
every once in a while in your life you
will meet
a man or a woman that's different
something about them is different you
will feel it you're gonna feel it and
you're gonna say
i don't know what it is about this guy
or this girl it's just different
about this guy or this girl they inspire
you
they think big they keep their award
they're driving
they're excited they want to do
something that's never been done before
there's that
energy that you feel right and the
longer you're with them and you witness
a level of consistency of this that's
not just
trash talk you know how you know watch
what i'm going to do it's not hot air no
no it's not hot
they're delivering results it's
continuously going in that direction
legit
you have to do whatever you can to be a
right-hand person because
long-term you're going to be locked in
if you do it right
so in this situation you got a guy that
came in and says this guy needs my help
dude tell me what you want me to do
i'm going to help explode this company
and he now is an entrepreneur
okay never been an entrepreneur he's an
entrepreneur
about to run a 2 trillion dollar company
1.7 1.8 whatever the number is
a 2 trillion dollar company and he's
replacing jeff bezos what a beautiful
story what a beautiful situation to have
a young guy that goes from there to
being where he's at today's still young
53 with this kind of responsibility just
tells you
uh by the way this camera keeps moving i
don't know what's going on here
something's going on here with the
camera i know you guys are addressing it
so
thanks yes i am all about this i'm
supportive of it i'm excited for him i
hope he won't question for jazzy yeah of
course
so if he was listening to the podcast
right now and you were on his board
giving him advice on how he could
possibly
mess it up and what to be careful with
are there any things you would prepare
him for or tell him
no i would need to be an insider to know
to give any kind of counsel here i
i am not qualified in this situation to
give him counsel because
he's been there since 1997 the only
thing is kind of like look
sometimes when you replace a big
character
you're you're always compared you know
to that character it's very difficult
it's not an easy situation and sometimes
i am sure they've hired a right
executive coaches and psychologists and
therapists
to get him to understand what to say and
what it really means you're not getting
this position because you have to be
jeff bezos we're not expecting to be
jeff bezos
you're not wired to be like jeff pesos
like it's very hard to be tim cook
everybody's constantly going to compare
you but whoever did that with tim cook
did it the right way because look at tim
cook he's got his own identity now he's
done a great job with the company yeah
it's a replacement game but it's more
about buddy you're not here to be me
you're here to keep the culture together
because that's
very important on amazon we have a
culture we got to keep this together
we have a vision we got to keep driving
for the vision you got to keep using
your abilities that were great you just
have more responsibilities now
and we're entrusting you to take this
company to the next level because we
believe it's you
so it's more that side it's late night
pressures
that's going to come and now
everything's on you and for somebody
that decides to be a ceo
you can turn down that position by the
way there was a guy a couple years ago
that everybody thought was going to be
the ceo of amazon what was his name who
what was the name of the guy that was
supposed to be the ceo of amazon it's
right here
uh jeff wilkie was supposed to be jeff
wilkie was supposed to be the ceo
what does it say jeff wilkie by the way
i don't see it it says note
note i don't check this out right here
yeah there was another guy that was
supposed to be oh okay jeff wilkie was
supposed to be the
ceo of amazon and guess what he did he
just said i don't want to do it
wow yeah you want the pressure no i
don't know i i just think the life
happens buddy you don't let me take my
100 million bucks but it's not even that
you don't
know the whole story you don't know i've
worked so hard i've been away from my
kids one of my kids is now using drugs i
got to get in to save my family
i just don't want to work that like that
anymore i want to be around my family i
want to i don't want to be the
face i don't want attention i don't want
to be on board calls grilling me on cnbc
i just don't want that i that was you
you did it i'm good i'm worth 200
million bucks i'm worth 50 million bucks
i mowed half a million
i have no desire to do it give it to
somebody else
many times these positions are turned
down by the person that they want to
give it to
yeah you know someone i'm saying that
the person they want to give it to and
he says now i just don't want to be a
ceo
i don't want that kind of responsibility
i got to give a shout out to well two
things
i'd like to circle back to mario because
i know he's starting a his own
youtube episode on uh the importance of
being a number two so he can probably
weigh in on that
but let's talk about being a ceo for a
second street team never forget
there it is you know i it's a team
this is actually a pretty funny story
about pat and eric you were there and so
was mickey
um oh mario was there too a couple days
ago we left we
were working crazy hours we're getting
here early we've been staying late we've
been setting up the office we've been
how to move
pat left probably like you know he said
i gotta go have dinner with the fam i
gotta see the fan maybe around eight
o'clock around eleven ten eleven o'clock
we all go to pat's house because that's
where um
eric's car was and we were all just kind
of catching rides and car pool and doing
our thing all right
and we get to pat's house and you know
there's it's gated so
um we go in the gate we park the car
we're making our moves
pat gets out of his car
that's sitting in the driveway hey guys
what's up
pat you've been sitting in the driveway
for what it seemed two hours
on a phone call we thought you went home
already still in the shelby
in the shelby like we we thought the car
was parked we thought we were just
getting the car and make a move all
right cool like you know
i'm high beaming you you're not even
noticing it's me you're lucky
you know looking at a completely
different angle i'm lost i'm lost i'm
ready because i told him i said i bet
you pat's
uh awake in the kitchen sitting there
following your messages
but here's the point as a ceo yeah you
get the glamour you're the jeff bezos of
the world you're the pbd you're making
the money you're the big shot
what people don't see is the fact that
it's freaking 10 o'clock at night
you're still sitting in your car two
hours later parked in your garage
yeah you probably haven't even walked in
and said hi to your family yet because
you're on i assume
an important phone call if you haven't
even gone in the house yet that's sort
of i mean you did a the video that went
viral the you know
90 seconds of an entrepreneur but is
that kind of what you're talking about
like the the the other side of like
oh my god people have no desire to be
there like i know a lot of talented
capable people who had no desire to
start their own company
zero i had a lot of people in the former
company i used to be part of i looked up
to i admired these men
many of them a guy named rich i admired
a lot of these guys
who could have started a company but
they never did why didn't they
is it capability is it capacity
is it that you can't run it is it you're
not smart enough absolutely not
it's do you want that life
it's a different life there's a big
difference between being
you know a person that's uh you know
behind closed doors you're making good
money and you're good but you don't have
the highest level of pressure that comes
to you
you can still make three phone calls
above you that the pressure's on them
and you simply share the pressure versus
boom all the pressure's with you it's a
different kind of a pressure it's not
for everybody look this is why
when you talk to certain like elon musk
said you want to be a founder you want
to be a founder of a company okay
perfect here's what it looks like
yeah you're gonna have no life okay
you're gonna work 80 90 100 hours a week
and you will have no life everything
comes to you you will not have you'll
have a lot of sleepless nights because
you have to make the right decisions you
have to get up in the morning and you
have to figure out what you need to be
doing
and it's on going non-stop
that's what it is it's the life but by
the way let me give you another thing
the life of a head coach you think a
head coach is an easy job in sports
every day are you kidding me you got to
be there at four o'clock studying this
guy's playbook you just lost a player
you got to replace this player there's
only five
quarterbacks on the right now that are
free agents and you gotta you're 62
years old urban meyer heart issues you
know
pressure's coming to you this is film
yes
it's not an easy but it's not for
everybody
it's not for the only place you look
good is once you win
and then they say you're a freaking g
good for you
there's a book that's called the hard
things about hard things i think it's uh
written
by horowitz son what's uh i don't know
his first name but it's it's also
horowitz
the hard things if you go search the
hard things about hard things
on amazon if you can so people can see
it on the screen here on the big screen
mario
the hard things about hard things he
talks about how he builds david horowitz
david horowitz yeah i think it's david
horowitz
who wrote ben horowitz okay david okay
right there go to the bottom right there
this book
if you haven't read this book phenomenal
book
you know what he explained you read this
book is this the father of the son
son this is the guy i gotcha so you read
the book by the way he's a three and a
half billion auto guy
type in david horowitz net worth or ben
horowitz net worth
i think he's at three and things may
have changed a lot he may be higher or
less but
he's up there he's a guy that killed it
himself uh
uh 2.8 right there business insider okay
forbes whatever the
uh yeah he's up there i don't know what
the founder of uh
go up no it doesn't show the number
anyways
he's he's he's done very very well for
himself when you read the book he's the
co-founder of anderson he's a big
hip-hop guy
big hip-hop guy big hip-hop he doesn't
look like a hip-hop guy he's a big
hip-hop guy
right well you're a big hit you're
you're a big you're a huge tv
94 you're a huge t-pain fan these days
you're so funny i'm gonna buy you a
drink
what is this new song what but you know
what he says in a book here's what he
says in the book
he actually outlines all the
ugly truth about building a company and
how many times he almost went out of
business before he sold the four billion
or whatever he sold the hard thing about
her the hard things about the hard
things
right so it's not it's for every one guy
that almost
made it you know for every one guy that
makes it and it's like at the top
that that that cemetery is filled with a
lot of people that could have
and should have and something happened
and they didn't make it it's not
it's not an easy game so you know
congratulations to this guy for doing it
yes i mean
some people don't like him some people
say i don't like the fact that he's
doing this because he's the reason why
parlor's out
so i gotta text you talk about andy
jazzy yes there's some people that don't
like
right now because he forced parlor out
so if you want to know who forced parlor
route this is the guy
this is the guy wow okay this is the guy
that had the influence of doing that and
so now
he is the face of amazon so again
it's interesting stuff going on over
there let's talk a little bit about oil
i don't know if you heard or not but uh
possible exxon
mobil chevron merger the biggest
merger of all time
the chief of executives of exxon mobil
and chevron spoke about combining the
oil giants after the pandemic
shook the world last according to the
people familiar with the talks
testing the waters for what could have
been one of the largest corporate
mergers
of all time such a deal would reunite
the two largest uh descendants of the
john d rockefeller standard oil company
which was broken up by the u.s
regulators in 1911 and reshaping the oil
industry by the way fy
if if rockefeller's wealth back in the
days
before he died if you compare it today
with
inflation and everything to get you know
what his network 340 billion dollar net
worth
he'd be number one he'd be number one
right he'd be combined
uh that's right rockefeller was a
rockefeller
a combined company market value could
top 350 billion dollars exxon has a
market value of 190 billion
while chevron 164. together they would
likely uh form the world's second
largest oil company by market cap
production producing about 7 million
barrels of
oil and gas a day based on pre-pandemic
levels second only in both measures to
saudi or a ram code think about it
that's a pretty big number right there
so what are your what are your thoughts
about this one
i did i did a little research on this
yeah and number one i
just how massive saudi aramco is
uh 1.7 trillion dollar company i think
the only company that's big as them
is apple as far as market share
um but here's here's actually something
pretty interesting
you know who the biggest company in the
world was in 2006 most
highest valued company in the world 2006
walmart no
who exxon exam okay okay so now we're
talking about them
um struggling so bad
that now they might potentially because
it's all just sort of hearsay
initial talks having to merge
with chevron just to compete in the
marketplace right now because under an
abide administration do you think
they're going to be pro
or against fully uh energy yeah and gas
and consumption 100
anti i mean i did an episode about you
know buying's going green i mean
clean energy green jobs so
this is all just initial talks right now
whether exxon and chevron but
you know 15 years ago exxon was the big
dog energy was the big dog around the
world
and now who are the big dogs tech apple
amazon obviously microsoft was there
then
um the tech is now the big dogs around
the world and energy is clearly
plummeting
well tesla as well they're making a big
tesla on them
with all their solar and all that uh
electric power tesla is tech big data
and clean energy not traditional correct
yeah
big oil you know exxon chevron
that type of energy yeah what are you
getting a
uh a tesla when are you getting
what are you getting uh uh you know uh
electric car electric you know what i
said
panamera electric what did you get that
car is pretty ridiculous and that wasn't
that i did have the i8 and i love the i8
i don't know if you've seen this what is
that bmw i8 the doors open up on this
side
pull it out mario i like that did you
drive the idea yeah i
drove to pick up your dad one time yeah
it was actually pretty good i mean it
wasn't really that
fast it was really 16 like 3.5 seconds
four seconds
right there it was faster than my saturn
yeah it is faster than your saturn for
sure so the i8
uh you drove this for a while yeah this
is the electric bmw
yeah i had this for two years really
that's the one the white and the blue
right at a mission impossible it is it's
like it's a car it's a nice so you had
an electric car
it's right there that's exactly what i
had i had that one right there okay
yeah i would charge it every day and
what was that like what was that life
like
let me tell you i don't even know why i
got rid of this car why did i get rid of
this car
you ended up getting i think it was the
orange lambo the aventador yeah
what well i got the uh i got the dawn i
got the i don't know why i got rid of
this car this was a phenomenal car it
was actually a very good car you know
i it was a very good everyday car is
what this was
very good everyday car and but you had
to charge it there was no gas stations
no you it's gas it was a combo gas it
was a hybrid it was gas
and electric so if i had the electric
great if i didn't i could get the gas as
well so can i answer your question on
the market
i kind of like that believe it or not i
kind of like that the hybrid approach
yeah i kind of like that because there
wasn't
enough chargers and i didn't have time
to go stand somewhere and wait for 15
minutes 20 minutes i'm like dude
how long does it take you to fill up
your tank yeah five minutes not even
whatever two minutes
how long does it take you to charge your
entire i don't even know that's it's a
it's a while it's not like a minute or
five minute thing you got to sit there
for some time right so
something like this you go in and it's
hybrid or worked out there some days i
forgot to charge it i'm gonna go to the
gas station and take care of that go
ahead mario yeah question for you a
little speculation just a question a
little bit a little deeper but
the biz doc did an episode last week i
think on tesla yeah we talked about
maybe elon's planning doing energy gas
stations do you think
if on these oil companies and they're
thinking next moves
strategically they're merging in order
to maybe take on the next big thing
do you think that could be a possibility
i think they're unified right now
because there's a lot of enemies
the next let's just say biden and kamala
go eight years
let's say a lot of people are saying
it's not gonna happen meaning kamala is
gonna be the face because biden may not
make it past four years health-wise we
don't know it's just pure speculation
but say they go eight years can you
imagine eight years of anti-oil agenda
non-stop
you have to pivot remember remember that
one episode we did about the
general motors where tom put up the
picture saying
that general motors website even though
they only sell three percent of their
cars are electric
you know on their website the only car
they had on general motors website was a
ceo standing next to their only electric
car even though they only sell
two to four percent of electric cars
their website says what wow electric
cars and they said
by 2025 i think cadillac is going 100 uh
20 35
20 30 20 30 or some number i don't know
if i was 20 35 or 20 25.
but it was in the next five days in the
next handful of years they're going
cadillac is going 100
electric so this doesn't was it cadillac
or their entire fleet it was cadillac
only
first and then they're going gm yes
so if you if you look at numbers exxon's
share fell 29
last year chevron fell 20 last year yeah
okay
the the the stock index of u.s oil and
gas companies was down 57
at one point in 2020 you know you you
have to
also the the challenge with exxon and
chevron goes these guys thought oil was
going to be around forever
and they took a hit by the way these oil
guys executives you know what kind of
money they make
they go golfing two three times a week
making a million dollars two million
dollars half a million dollars
regular executives who are not even
working making that kind of money
because they think this is going to be
around forever
and unfortunately this happens in many
newspapers
fat and lazy radio oh are you kidding me
of course
they're getting fat and lazy you can't
go like this forever and elon musk is
officially forcing
chevron and mobile exxon to get back to
work
and elon musk is forcing these guys
who've been kicking the golf in three
four five times a week
to get back to work because if you don't
your business model is no longer working
oh my god today
well i mean right here it says it was um
was it exxon which was
america's most valuable company seven
years ago this isn't
a hundred years ago with a market share
of more than 400 billion nearly double
chevrons all right
exxon has fallen from its heights
following a series of strategic missteps
which were further exacerbated
by the pandemic we all remember back in
march oil went to
you know zero dollars a barrel right
what was going on right there
but here's the biggest point right here
it was removed from the dow jones
industrial average
last year for the first time since it
was added as standard oil
in 1920 scary thought to be so 90 years
ago it's it's
it's removed from dow jones for the
first time in 90 years
since 1928. so that alone ought to tell
you what direction this is going to
right now this is this is not a joke
like these guys
are you know i don't know if they're
sitting there panicking right now
but i think they're saying listen man we
know we can't stand each other you're
you're exxon you're chevron look let's
just kind of team up
we have a common enemy just come
together and try to make this work and
be on the same team together what do you
say
great so it's not going to be that
pretty but it's not a bad move that
they're making
so we'll see what's going to happen
there with this by the way um
let's see which one we go to you brought
up the fact what might happen in the
next
four to eight years you want to talk
this might be a good segue for odds
candidates yeah i mean go for it 20 24
candidates okay
yeah eric do you have an opinion on this
on who do you think is going to be
2024 republican candidates
who do you think i think i would love to
see it
and and we'll see if it happens but dan
crenshaw and
uh tulsi gabbard vp a combination and i
think the republican side
yes oh no republican ticket dan crenshaw
being the vp
i think would be because she's she's you
know pretty moderate
and i would like to see that happen i
don't know two military by the way how
did you come up with that have you just
been thinking about it
i just thought of speculation i like
their personality i like that they're
logical somewhere or no
it's just me speculating i feel like
tristan combination you just proposed i
i actually
uh fully kind of endorse where you're
going with this this is a republican
a reasonable moderate republican if you
guys don't know who dan crenshaw is
he's the guy with a patch on his eye
pete davidson on saturday live made fun
of the guy he had to retract that
a new policy now dan crenshaw has blown
up by the way not a trump guy
crenshaw i mean he's voted with him in
congress yeah yeah i think he's in the
house he's not a senator right who
he's a congressman congressman so he's
in the house uh
not he's not uh toned the company line
so to speak he's got his own opinions
right they're both congressmen yeah and
we'll tell uh
tulsi gabbard is no longer um
an active congresswoman she i think
she's no longer in office right now
if you're watching this who do you think
who do you think 20 24 candidates i'm
curious i want to hear from you as well
who do you think
if you were to pick candidates in 2024
running who would be on your list but go
ahead you were saying something
no i i do like the fact i think this is
what this country needs a republican
uh you know a moderate republican a
moderate democrat coming together and
running under one ticket saying guys
we don't have to be so extreme it
doesn't need to go socialism all the way
to the left the aoc doesn't need to be a
candidate
we don't need to have a you know what we
won't call names but whatever trump was
doing
all the way to the right and you know
the the conspiracy theorists and the q
and on and the
two like we need to again get back to
center
paul what do you think do you have
anybody in mind uh
well i've heard about donald trump jr
okay being a possible candidate uh
uh donald trump um
tulsi gabbard was actually gabbard
[Music]
mario who do you have anybody or no not
really no idea
do you know the odds no you know the
odds you got yeah i got them out give me
something
i got some answers you know who is the
highest odds like most likely candidate
nikki haley who do you think it is the
highest odds today best odds
yes rand paul would be another name
descendants listen gabard relax who do
you have as a high standard okay highest
odds this is according to
uh a betting website okay
number one best odds
you want to guess there's no way they're
gonna have trump as the highest odds
you sure about that is he the highest
trump plus 800 as a wild card
plus 800 right so the the lower your
number the more likely so for instance
right now
you bet a hundred bucks you win 800
bucks exactly you know who the favorite
is
who in 2024 like the favorite you're
gonna tease me how much forward
i'm not talking i'm not oh baby i'm
gonna tease
your favorite so the favorite right now
to be president in 2024
yeah kamala harris plus 450. i'm with
that
biden plus 600. okay so meaning they
project
harris is more likely to be president
coffee 2024 coffee it's a tea you don't
drink coffee
it's a tea oh it's a it's a london fox
okay come here
you'll need a little soy for that good
buddy keep going so somali
is plus 450 biden's plus 600 plus 800
number two nikki haley at plus
1200 mike pence at plus 1600
and then we have um ted cruz at plus
senator josh hawley at plus 4 000
mark cuban plus 2500 so he's got better
odds
than cruz and haley as a republican as a
republican
uh your boy dan crenshaw plus 5 000
and your boy donald trump jr plus
five thousand so that is the most likely
to least
likely candidates and then you have gop
congresswoman marjorie taylor green
she's also the news
plus 10 billion she ain't gonna be
president if you know who that is yeah
no for your bettors out there though so
let me let me give some names here let
me give you some names here what you got
abbott okay one texas yes let me tell
you why okay
he's done a good friend pandemic no he's
done a good job don't go forget about
friends i'm saying he's done a good job
during the academic okay texas
number one i would i wouldn't put him
number one i'm just saying
putting him on the list i know kai's got
a list here guys got trump haley cruz
uh uh holly pants cotton
but i think abbott is one seriously to
consider
taxes i think the other one is desantis
let me tell you why
watch this um the nba
playoffs last year what was their main
campaign what would they campaign in
the entire time they're the nba bubble
and social justice
but what was it what was everybody
wearing everybody was wearing what
social justice
black lives matter yeah right okay so a
liberal organization decided to hold
their playoffs
in a conservative state ran by a
conservative republican desantis
right so the nba playoffs goes there
super bowl goes to florida they're right
now trying to bully japan saying if you
don't get your act together we will
gladly hold the olympics
yes in florida because we know how to do
it right so
you got to give credit to desantis right
okay and desantis is not a pushover
he's solid he can hang in there and he's
a pretty strong guy
and he's got good argument to give on
what they've done young guy too is
probably in his early 40s and watch this
can you imagine
if he does and somehow cuomo gets
involved
he will crush cuomo he's going to say
all your guys came to me
all your business people came to me so
that would be a i'd love to see the
stage of cuomo going up against
desantis or seeing abbott going up
against newsom
i'd love if newsome runs and these guys
somehow get on the same stage
mcgregor we're watching mcgregor
fighting against i'm like what a week i
said
what did i say to you you're so pissed i
was i'm like i don't even i've
wasted my custody i was so disgusted by
it you wanted him to win
you got a guy you think you're gonna
you're gonna anyways it's just very
frustrating this is upsetting you i'm a
fan
i'm a fan but the money you got a couple
hundred million dollars from proper 12
and you're going there either don't
fight or fight the guy's he's so
exciting
mcgregor i wanted khabib mcgregor and
that's not going to happen now khabib
made fun of him say this may never
happen again yeah
right and even dana said it may never
happen after what just took place and
then he had the drug stuff that came up
which is six month suspension that's a
whole different story so drug stuff
uh connor connor had a uh uh yeah i
think conor got suspended kai can you
verify this i think connor got suspended
for six months or something like that
yeah
so so so you're a sleeper right there
you're a sleeper yeah you called mario
kai no no i actually kai's texting
okay yeah you're basically saying your
sleeper is desantis
if you can pull off i think so so abbott
desantis pompeo i don't know if he's a
guy that could be a president
let me throw another curveball for you
here let me throw another curveball for
you i don't know if it's going to happen
this year maybe it's going to happen in
the next eight to 12 years maybe 16
years
uh kushner's a genius ivanka i think
can run people love her and even the
left
respects her when she's saying kushner
or ivanka or you're saying they're
running
either or either or because remember
kushner is not a republican
kushner is a center-right center
sometimes center or left and ivanka is
not fully a republican ivanka's a
center-right is where she's at and she
can go on the view and they're very
respectful to ivanka the way she is
right
so abbott desantis
trump uh uh ivanka kushner
uh tim scott which we've already talked
about i love what you said with tulsa
gabbard
dan crenshaw sure he hasn't had enough
publicity online
uh on media you know the whole thing
that happened with saturn life was good
i'm gonna throw a crazy curveball in
there crazy kerber because you know
the usual suspect everybody throws
here's a crazy one
that would be so interesting and by the
way i'd love to see cuban get in it
i'd like i told cubans four years ago i
told him four years ago and we said
i said i said so what's your you know
i'd love to see i'd love to see him get
in it because i think
i think he pisses off both sides i don't
think cuban is a democrat i don't think
he's a republican
i think he is center left he's not a
republican but he center like
slightly like just a little bit left
okay is where he is at center left on
certain issues
center right on certain issues closer to
economy okay
but i don't know why i would love to see
tucker carlson run
tucker carlson you don't even know how
much i'd love to see him run
you don't know how bad i'd love to see
him run really i'd love to see him run
no support from the left oh zero yeah i
don't know if he's made no friends
well no wait a minute he's he's also
called out to trump he's called out the
right he's called out things that the
right is done so
you have to know that there's an element
of the right that also
doesn't like tucker so it's not like he
is he'll get up there and say stuff like
dude what are you doing are you a
republican or are you democrats
uh what's her name really badly who's
what's her face the trump's lawyer the q
and on lady the
yeah yeah yeah uh hardcore
i don't know who you were today what was
your latest
name sandy sydney sydney powell sydney
powell he's the first one that was like
yo sydney show us the proof
yeah you're talking about big games
you're talking hugo chavez you're
talking dominion yeah a little bit too
much so
that's what i'm trying to tell you now a
billion dollar loan what i'm trying to
tell you is
i can see that you know if he was to get
it now here's a challenge why a guy like
that may not get in
you know why a guy like that may not get
in because a guy like that
is about to be a free agent and he's
probably going to land a hundred to 150
million dollar contract wow so him
running could cost him 150 million bucks
like the money buddy that's probably
what's gonna end up happening
the reason why some of these guys like
imagine bill o'reilly never ran why
maybe a little bit of personal life i
don't know
some of these guys never ran but you can
i think we've experienced that we
there's a big difference between winning
you know your primary and the republican
party versus thank you baby
for uh winning listening to this
national election from jen yeah
thank you uh you know what that reminds
me of pat with with the tucker carlson
pick is
uh a few years back and this didn't end
up a success story but
there's other names that can't come to
my mind but in the nfl
uh matt millen who was a former player
yeah he was a color commentator
and then he had no front office
experience but then he jumped
into uh the gm role of the detroit lions
but to me that'd be kind of a similar
thing where it's like you watch it and
you're studying you're analyzing
it so you have a better maybe
understanding than a lot of
people from the from from inside so you
have a nice outside perspective but then
you don't necessarily
have all that experience but sometimes
that could work for you
so i kind of like that philosophy yeah i
don't know i like him
something about him i like you know like
like here's what's crazy
and people get up so when i say this
there's something about
uh chris coma i like i don't know
there's something about jon stewart i
love
i'm so glad he's back on twitter by the
way jon stewart just got on twitter i
don't know if you guys heard it or not
he's officially on twitter he was never
on twitter gets back on twitter and if
you guys have like go on go on his
twitter account so we can see what he
says
you're a fan of john stewart i'm a fan
of jon stewart because i
said he's left he no he's not
he's center left he center left he
called that nancy pelosi on his show and
made her look like a fool
and he went up there and fought for the
firefighters from
i don't know 911 he's left i don't know
if he's as left as you think he is i
think he's center-left
but i think we need him i think i mean
go to twitter go type in john's to uh
just type in twitter on the top
no no just for jon stewart uh uh okay go
to twitter and type in john stewart
two t's ooh so you guys are in the same
community twitter
got it got it so kai
mario's making you look good today okay
yeah if you watch you know kai
somewhere in america something he's kind
of somewhere right now celebrating you
said you said
type in uh go to his account john
stewart uh
i'm not sure what it is oh my gosh i
can't believe somebody help us out here
go to maybe he's not on there no he is
under he's 100
under he just he just has a unique oh
right there the the dog all the way in
the bottom
all the way that's him yeah believe it
or not that's him click on that okay one
million followers he's following one
person and the one person he's following
i think is wendy's i think
is it wendy's and he trashes them on a
tweet but go back
we have the tweet go back
okay so he puts up on the 31st i believe
compromise is the heart
and that out of progress demands
concessions so to the right in exchange
for universal healthcare i will uh
allow all the future mario what are you
doing i'm reading mario what are you
doing i'll
all future space leaders to be non
denominational
what compromise do you propose remember
there are no bad ideas unity
the stuff he says yes i've come back on
you much like one of your nasty nasty
sandwiches
arby's right because arby's said that
thanks for whatever so if i do
really well on here i get to be
president yes
he's got 485 that's mocking trump yeah i
think it's cool though i think i think
stuart
you know i enjoy his perspective i i i
don't know if
carson's going to run or not but i think
that kind of a personality would be very
interesting
eventually shapiro is going to run yeah
eventually shapiro is going to run it
just may not be in the next 15 years
eventually he's going to i think i hear
that i think we would do a disservice if
we didn't address the
most likely leading contender other than
trump himself is nikki haley
she's a reasonable let's just let me
just read a little bit of what people
said here's what people said the
sanderson gnome okay tulsi and jocko
uh desantis and tulsi said amya madison
tulsi said dennis
mcgriff marilyn joseph says candace
owens
ian uh wins says patrick david 2024
how about patrick bay david soyboy pbd
soyboy campaign we got to pick out 2024.
this will be here we got we got to make
sure we'll put our face on a milk cart
and done that we'll get nancy on that
right now
carton okay tulsi tulsi tulsi says
priyoman
roy chandley tulsi trump and tulsi trump
and tulsi
shapiron crowder uh uh
shapiro and crowd of mark cuban uh
doesn't matter who was president 2024
and you got ted cruz tulsi crenshaw
haley tim scott same name tulsi
has been demonized and ostracized by the
democratic party by the way this is
what's needed
meeting more people talking about you in
different platforms tulsi's makes made
herself so relevant and different
people want her this is very good it's
good time to have momentum because she's
got three years to create that kind of
momentum
it's actually a very good sign that
other people are saying this
uh uh who also pbd and sauce urban
jack okay so we got more anyways a lot
of people are saying you know different
names
but you said the leading candidate okay
one person here brando commander gave
five dollars and said i got republicans
matt gates
okay no way good-looking guy you're not
a you're not a fan of matt gates
i mean he's shonda's cousin by the way
so ted cruz really
josh hawley greg abbott the sanders
democrats kamala harris newsom bob i
grammar cuban
good list bob iger newsom
when you say someone like iger say i'm
thinking who can get
out of the primary and actually win the
general
someone like bob iger can someone like
nikki can
okay tiger okay so he would be president
can
bob could be president yes and he wants
to by the way okay
democrats like him uh smart business guy
traditional conservatives you know i
don't know if he'll have the maga
community
nikki he's he's left okay yeah but his
family parents are left and he grew up
wanting to
we've all seen you could do great like
ted cruz could do great in the
republican primary that guy's never
going to be president i'm sorry
um matt gates you got to understand from
someone who
you know kind of views himself as center
left i'm looking at these names and i'm
saying there's no way matt gates is
ever going to be president united states
with the what he's done
and pissing off people on the left just
like someone like aoc is never going to
be president because no one on the right
would
ever vote for her so you need to have
someone who could
reach out to the other side and get
votes that's what trump was able to do
in 2016.
biden took some votes from trump in 2020
obama was able to do that in 2012
big tent baby so ted cruz i don't see it
i don't see trump jr
i do see a nikki haley i do see
even a tom cotton i do see a tulsi
gabard
uh yeah i see what you did there yeah i
got a name for you guys
here we go this just started percolating
my head this is a little out there
but stop it he's got different
experiences which i like
ice cube i thought you were going to say
john elway or something because of how
hard of a guy you want ice cubes run a
business he's he's in multiple platforms
i got someone for you he's a person
kanye
kanye he's going to be he's going to be
the guy but ice cube is
is rational no and and he he's
he i think he grew up probably on the
left he's got more conservative
principles now
he's he's kind of all over place he's
polarizing in a good way
you ain't got no job you only got no
place to go
it's friday ain't nobody gonna have i'm
gonna get you high today but i can see
that shirt though straight out of the
white house
straight out of the way i'm telling you
guys this is a marketing marketing
yeah marketing pat i don't know how much
time we have
one hour ago one hour ago news just came
out and it's trending on twitter
what's going on jeff zucker cnn
president is going to be stepping down
by the end of the year
oh jeff zucker from cnn is going to be
stepping up our friend that was
recording all his uh
conversations what was that what what
was that yeah yeah
it's uh announces plans to step down one
hour ago that's cnn
okay so he is stepping down um
what is the veritas project veritas
what's the guy's name from project
veritas i don't know the guy's name
okay james o'keefe yeah he had a
recording of their calls that he had and
he
made it public and people listened to it
so i don't know if that's the case i
think cnn
is taking a massive hit i think
that's what i was going to say is what's
the upside for him staying trying to i
mean
ratings are going to be lower for for
news media
over the next four years with biden he's
just not
people just obviously don't give a [ __ ]
what he has to say as much as trump
whether you like trump or not
you listen to trump i think he said
listen i dealt with the trump era i'm
out let me just take my couple hundred
million
and keep it moving uh but we're talking
about odds here
yeah we're in florida we talked about
desantis we talked about the nba bubble
what's this weekend it's superb mario
who do you got tell us
who should we be betting god uh-oh i
don't bet against goats
so wow well we got straight up we got
the real goat versus the baby they're
gonna
go for tom peretti so you're saying
brady's gonna win it
yes so tampa based you're gonna put
brady against mahomes
yes okay he's gonna take a young buck a
lesson you think so
that'll be twice he lost in the playoffs
by the way you're gonna paul what are
you saying yeah
uh i'm rooting for by the way paul
actually
no sports paul actually knows big time
i'm rooting for the buccaneers i think
they have a puncher's chance
but the chiefs are the better and more
consistent team
did you hear about the whole culvert
thing with the chiefs yeah no the barber
got covered and he cut 20 guys here
and they all do you know the players
have to test negative five days in a row
to play
on five days ago pat mahomes got the
haircut with the barber as well
unbelievable yeah that's pretty crazy if
you lose because of a barber
i mean barbara i mean the guys from
vegas are going to go
find this barber you're going to say
damn it you cost me 20 million bucks
i think they would push the super bowl i
think there was zero chance they would
oh really bro the super bowl is being
played in tampa this weekend i don't
know what's going on
if half of the chiefs are out they're
going to push the super bowl
by the way who else has said what you
just said right now uh
probably no one i don't know i've never
they're not gonna push the super bowl no
you can't you can't phys if you lose
half your team
because it's not like a replacement
buddy that's your responsibility you
should have followed the guidelines and
being a little bit more responsible
i get that part but you can't you can't
play the super bowl with half your team
and and what you you can't just say it's
a tie or
do you understand the amount of
preparation they've put into having the
freaking super bowl three days from now
i get it but
like everything that they're doing all
the sports league about flexibility
that's not what you put in your bench i
mean then that we have like no you don't
have a million players
the super bowl is going to be this
weekend you will lose listen house
i haven't dropped your halls you will
lose so
so eric you got anybody or nobody okay
sam you got anybody or nobody who
bucks yeah who do you have paul you said
the chiefs cheese
but i'm rooting for the box okay who you
got well i'm gonna use your words
to prove my point here what's that okay
uh tom beardy's the goat
yeah patrick mahomes the baby goat
patrick mahomes they're they're the
favorite kfc's favorite minus three yeah
we talked about odds
patrick mahomes what do you do this past
offseason he signed a new
500 million dollar extension
right half a billion bucks almost
whatever it was biggest ever
here's i'm going to use give me a guy
give me a guy with experience
with the guy with money the guy with the
money is going to walk with experience
the guy with experience is going to walk
away
i'm rooting for the bucks tom brady
that's my guy i've been rude
and in college i skirted by by running
book and i took uh
tom brady's first super bowl 2001
patriots were plus 14 points
this is obviously under the belichick
era they beat the rams the greatest show
on turf
so i haven't gone against by the way
okay let me ask you if you're watching
this
push thumbs up if you got the bucks push
thumbs down
if you got the chiefs i'm actually
curious push thumbs up if you got the
bucks push
thumbs down if you got the chance to be
clear comment don't push the
no no no no no no smash that button
right there not comment no no not
comments you want them
i want them to i don't care if it's a
negative comment or not i don't really
want to
hit the thumbs down because that's how i
can track it i see right now 795 to
seven so if i
see this i'm look buddy right here okay
so 7.95 just okay so more people think
the bucks are going to win really
i think everybody's just rooting for tom
brady but if you actually look
at the logistics this is going to come
down to pass rush
whoever gets the generates more of a
passer is going to win this all right
there matt millen
this guy this guy's going deep over yeah
well look championship game though
another concern tom brady
is throwing is is having a lot of
turnovers right now
we all know our community ain't come
here for the sports pat we just give us
your prediction yeah
pat mahomes patrick bet david who you
got let let me
let me give you if both happens let me
give you if both happens i'll kind of
give it to you from
a different way if mahomes wins mm-hmm
that's like
kobe always wanted to face lebron in the
playoffs yeah you know
kobe if kobe goes in the finals
if cobra is jordan if kobe goes against
the in the finals against jordan and
beats the bulls
there's always that argument yeah okay
the the reason why lebron for the rest
of his
life is going to have the argument of
you're not the greatest
is because you know six
lebron oh you're jordan six
championships six for six all this stuff
there is moments in history that you
have to really capitalize
this may be mahomes most important game
of his lifetime for legacy
purely for legacy because if mahomes
beats i just got the chills if mahomes
beats
brady yeah the chances of brady going
back to the
super bowl slim to none at this point
running it back i'm not going to say
something i'ma say 10 here's why
who's the most pissed off person in the
world this weekend probably bill
belichick
no one's more pissed off in the world
than bill belichick nobody is more
pissed off than bill belichick
you did this without me bro he's got 60
million dollars to play with
he's going to put a team together okay
he's about
he's got a 60 million dollar who does
salary that's got opening to play with
he is going to put a team together
that's going to scare the hell out of
everybody belichick
belichick you don't give belichick 60
million dollar budget for you why does
he have 60 million dollars he got that's
the number he's got because his camera
salary cap salary caps got 60 million
gotcha watch what this guy's gonna come
back with
which means what brady's the most hated
player as competitor
competitor because he keeps winning
nobody like nobody like jordan nobody
likes
as a company nobody like kobe everybody
like kobe when he retired and was
shooting 27 from the field oh we love
kobe
yeah because he's not going to beat you
anymore you hated kobe 10 years ago you
love kobe now right
they still hate brady because he's still
in the super bowl oh yeah okay
uh if he beats brady fast forward 10
years from all the stephen a smiths and
max kellermans and skip bayless they're
all debating on tv underground
but the last time brady went to super
bowl he lost two patent homes
yeah and that's why pat mahomes is now
the goat because he beat the prior goat
and brady has to sit there for the rest
of his life listening to those
interviews
so for mahomes lots of pressure for
brady
a lot of pressure because brady knows
mahomes can take it away from him
so they both have a lot of pressure a
ton
my prediction here's my prediction
whoever gets sacked two times in the
first quarter loses
okay whoever gets sacked two times in
the first quarter
loses the super bowl very simple if
brady gets sacked twice in the first
quarter he's gonna lose
if mahomes gets sacked two times on the
first quarter he loses what's your
what's your analogy you gotta
shake the guy up because there's so much
pressure shake them up
sack them twice in the first quarter
then you have a shot okay
i think that's my prediction i may be
wrong that mario were you trying to say
something
this time yeah that that'd be my
prediction so give us a final score
let's do it
i uh i don't know i think uh you know uh
last week when brady won tampa bay had a
solid defense so i'm
you know you know kc so i'm i'm kind of
a
i'm going tampa based defense believe it
or not i'm going tampa based defense
wins the championship
that's my bet so uh i could be wrong you
know
that my bet is tampa based defense going
to win the super bowl so
again i hope you're right pat i hope
you're right as well
but you better respect this my home's
kid he's
likable he's crazy he's a great teammate
they love him
he's a good captain he's a good face of
the league in every possible way
the nfl got so lucky having them homes
so lucky to have them homes because the
nba the nfl is locked in the next 10
years
just because they have a good face right
mahomes is such a great face for the
league
so if he wins i won't be upset but i'd
like to see
my prediction is tampa bay's defense
gonna understand paul
how far is uh tampa bay from here asking
for a friend
probably uh you know less than four
hours three hours away
yeah all right so with the last thing by
the way let me let me do one more here
to see if the odds changed or not
uh yeah it's still people are saying
brady's gonna win hey if you enjoyed
today's podcast smash that subscribe
we're back
we're back we are back i don't know how
many times we're gonna get back to but
we are back and uh
you know we're gonna mix things up and
uh depending on how this does and it
grows
we will increase the level of commitment
we put into this don't get me wrong we
had a lot of fun
we enjoyed this ourselves i've really
enjoyed this it's a very busy time of my
life right now these guys know how busy
i am because they see me every day what
my life looks like mario yesterday came
in
at 11 30 i'm what what'd i look like you
said when he came into the house
phone to the right leg extended face
down knocked out listen to audiobook
like this i was listening to the motives
knocked out on the couch because i'm
trying to finish this audio but i'm
gone i said why don't you wake me up
this is pat
i went i had two tangerines i opened the
fridge i walked around it got
noise you still i kept saying pat pat
pat you're still in wait you needed some
sleep
woke up you know whose fault you know
whose fault it was what's that i'll go
no go ahead
i woke up at four o'clock this morning
and everything was about notes no it's
strategy strategy no it's not
four o'clock i couldn't sleep you know
what i blame your friend jerry on the
airplane didn't let you see
jerry you know what ken jerry oh by the
way i gotta give a shout out to a friend
ruth two people i gotta give a shout out
to and i know like
ruth i i'm at the beach the other day
celebrating tico's birthday tico turned
nine years old my son
my first son i'm so i love this guy
so proud of a man on what he's doing and
who he's becoming but turned nine years
old
the other day uh dylan says hey dad
people in school ask me if my daddy's
rich what do you say i say you don't go
bragging about if your daddy's rich or
not but they're asking
i said no our family's business is our
family's business and dylan says
so i said what are you going to say if
they ask you well if they ask me i'm
going to say
we keep those kind of information to
ourselves
[Laughter]
yeah but i don't know if i'm comfortable
with that because if they ask
i want to answer because i don't want to
lie i said tico what would you say
my dad has money but he's very modest
you realize the first time i used the
word modest i was in my late 30s like
what do you mean modest you know
nine years old nine years old he says my
dad's modest but
shout out to ruth we're at the beach i'm
hanging out with the kids
celebrating tico's birthday mario is
there melva's there you know
mickey was there as well i think yeah
mickey was there as well then
all of a sudden i started talking to
this family because the kite i was using
all of a sudden this
husband and wife are saying they're
concerned because the wind is moving it
boom comes down crashing they thought it
was going to hit him i missed them by
like six feet
and so they're like okay i'm glad it
didn't hit us i said no it's all right
it's cold so we start talking to them we
exchange phone numbers
then i walk away this lady is nursing
her kid
and sitting there with her family with
her husband jonathan i think that's his
name she's got a 12 year old a
nine-year-old a five-year-old and a
three-month-old baby
this lady that's sitting right there she
says you have one other fan
here i say do i look at her husband he
says no
ruth probably late 60s
early 70s she says i listen to the
entire podcast and what you guys say
and i promise ruth before i forget ruth
shout out to you she's from
upstate new york an hour north of
new york is visiting her niece here just
had a very
pleasant conversation with the family if
ruth you are listening
shout out to you and the last shout out
i do want to give is i posted this on
instagram i just kind of want to say
this here is because
as a kid i was growing up i had uh i got
a call last week with
from my sister and she said uh luther
al-jazeera passed away i call him uncle
luther but you know luther al-jazeera
passed away at 95 years old this is a
syrian man who was very successful he
owned country clubs
golf clubs he lived in a beautiful home
in a cul-de-sac right next to snoop dogg
with
a you know birds what do you call it
cage with collection of birds and his
jaguars parked outside in a
basketball court a tennis court a pool
jacuzzi
you know just the whole thing this is
like this was a guy i looked up to that
young gage every summer i would go to
his house once my dad would take me
there
and i would watch him you know wouldn't
speak to him because he was
luther but i would watch him he had a
picture of himself and al gore in the
billiard room he had a picture of
himself as an entire family like 30 of
them
all dressed in white and he would sit
there and debate his kids
why did jesus do this what do you think
is going on with this who's going to win
the championship i disagree with you
would constantly inject debate in their
family right
and i looked at him i said what does
this guy do dad he's a business owner so
one day i want to be like him
from that age 13 14 15 16 17 every time
summertime i'd go seaman and i joined
the military didn't see him again
but i said i'm gonna go be successful
because if this guy ran a business i'm
gonna do the same thing as well you know
how he started his business this is how
he became a millionaire what a great
story he's at a bar
this is the myth everybody says no one
knows the 100 truth but that's the story
yeah
he's at a bar a guy on the side of the
bar says hey man i got a big
load i'm trying to move up to russia but
i need a massive truck and i don't know
how to do it and i'm willing to pay
premium for it and he says man
let me see what i can do about this at
the end of the bar a guy
is selling him a massive truck
not a bigger than 18-wheeler to move
stuff and he tells the guy
how much you're selling your truck for
because this guy's going out of business
he gives him a dollar amount he goes to
this guy and says how much you willing
to pay me advance
the advance he gives him ends up giving
him enough money to buy the truck he
takes the truck
moves the stuff to russia makes his
money
comes back starts a transportation
company and leaves iran on time when the
two man was only a few dollar few two
men a dollar
comes here with the money becomes
successful runs the business he's got
the best
best man everybody in his family is so
accommodating these people have treated
me royally
his son vladimir when i was a kid i was
part of a uh
organization called the new century uh
century city
new century city basketball association
where they brought troubled teens you
know
from mata sabatrucha from blood [ __ ] you
know everybody and we would play
basketball and he was our coach so he
kind of brought kids together and he was
great with us
not on his son gotcha and i wasn't at
the best phase of my life at that time
14 year old knucklehead
and he injected belief and he was
patient this entire family
so two years ago uh i'm so glad this
happened because he needed to hear it
from me two years ago where i brought
this place maybe a year and a half ago
mario either you were with me or tikka
was with me we were at rafi's place
and i spot him so i get up and i go to
him paul may have been you i don't know
who was with me one of you guys was with
me
i go up to him and his daughter is there
and uh jackie and she's like hey how you
doing you know all this stuff and i say
uncle
i have to tell you something i i think
you have to hear from my mouth he says
what
i said you changed my life i am who i am
today
because of you you inspired me when
there was no example of massive success
in business
and life i loved my dad he shaped me to
be a man but in business i never had it
you were it because of you at a young
age you inspired me to become who i am
today without you i am not where i'm at
today
you see tears in the guy's eyes really i
said look you probably have impacted so
many people but
i wanted you to hear this from my mouth
and he remembered you and he of course
remembers him we've had many
conversations
yes yes he starts getting emotional and
sits down and i go back and have my
dinner
and then last week i get a call from
paulette and he passed away so broke my
my spirit was broken for a day because
this is one of those uh special assyrian
leaders
amongst other leaders and uh you know i
look forward to uh
uh replacing and setting a great example
for that community so i just wanted to
give a shout out to the entire al-khasi
family
i love you guys may he rest in peace my
condolences goes out to you
and your entire family the syrian
community lost
an incredible leader but his example is
going to develop so many great
leaders to represent around the world of
what other young
assyrian leaders can do so shout out to
the entire classic family
uh and those of you guys that don't know
who he is it's it's uh uh it's important
to me i wanted to take this moment this
platform to
give that shout out to the family i
appreciate you guys that stuck around to
listen to this
uh had a good time on the podcast here
with everybody uh again
uh can't wait to do this again i think
we have a schedule for next tuesday what
time
so the challenge with it is we're
debating whether we do 8 a.m
eastern standard time so let me ask you
guys this question because this is what
since you guys are here
until the end and and uh you're pretty
much the true valuetainers that are here
with us
at the end do you want us to do it 8 a.m
eastern standard time
or 9 00 a.m eastern standard time here's
the difference
i want to do 8 a.m okay i want to do 8
a.m so
8 00 a.m means 5 a.m california
9 a.m means 6 o'clock california but the
content that we talk about it's
worldwide so some of you guys are europe
some of you guys are saudi arabia some
of you guys are dubai so
we got people from all over the world do
you want to see 8 a.m
eastern or 9 a.m if it's 8 a.m
press thumbs up if it's 9 a.m put thumbs
down i'm curious which one you want to
see so let's take a look here
8 a.m 8 a.m 8 a.m 9 9 9
8 9 8 8 8 8. so everybody is it possible
to do a poll
on instagram i tell you it's looking
like it's eight
more people are asking oh by far are you
seeing it or no yeah i'm looking at cars
are you looking at it it's more eight
than nine a.m
uh andrew said you'll lose west coast
i'll probably get lose you for an hour
and you'll join me
join me at six so here's what i say we
do
here's what i say we do based on what a
lot of people are saying 8 a.m
next week we will test tuesday
8 a.m fair got it next week who's am i
in town next tuesday or no
z said we're confirmed but the following
week i'm not here at all so we're not
going to do podcasts two weeks from now
but next week i'm here the entire week
we post on uh vitamin instagram okay so
we'll figure it out so next week we're
for sure tuesday thursday yes
okay so next tuesday let's lock it in 8
a.m
eastern standard time 5 a.m
west coast pacific standard time good so
you just got it
next tuesday we're testing eastern so
that's an hour
earlier than we usually start we're
going to test it and we're going to see
data's going to tell us what's going to
happen
uh uh say that again lock it up adam
yeah so that's what we got here again
hey guys if some of you guys were new or
smash that subscribe button thanks for
joining us for the last couple hours
really enjoyed looking forward to
getting back to this
adam happy birthday bro thank you
special
special shout out to you with your
birthday take care everybody bye bye bye
bye